Three,
two,
one was a.
was this beverage concocted by you?
First one?
Yes.
You.
You created right brain.
If you asked me.
Yes.
If he has Dudley,
what does he say?
He was saying maybe he was there.
Maybe he was there,
but it might have been there.
He was definitely there.
Yeah.
But whose idea?
It's hard to say with these things.
Show cheers.
Good to see you.
You look good.
You look good to get better with this
shirt,
right?
That shirt.
The new Benno Brian Special.
Get that shirt.
Can you get this from your website?
We'll go to the mediator.
The mediator.com.
You go to the store and it's there.
Yeah.
So what people uh,
you know I had steven,
Steven Rinella,
our good friend and we were talking
about what they're doing with what
mediators doing.
This is very strange thing where there's
this giant multimedia corporation has
stepped in and throwing a ton of money
at mediator and all these different
companies that are involved in the
outdoors.
All these outdoor activities.
That is true and they're putting it all
together into one super network
Juggernaut,
a juggernaut of outdoor activities.
True.
It's true.
Yeah.
Uh,
it is,
um,
something.
I've never been a part of it before.
Something like I've never seen before in
the hunting industry.
Has it ever existed before?
I don't think so.
No,
Can't be.
So we would have known about what better
to try than something that's never been
done.
Well,
you had been doing your podcast for
what?
Like a year now.
How long have you been doing?
About 10 months now.
Ten months.
And uh,
and we were just saying that I tried to
get you to do one five years ago.
Five years ago.
Yeah.
Ben and I met on a moose hunt in British
Columbia and I would say that it was
like friendship at first.
We had a great fucking time,
a great fucking time.
Shout out to Mike Cochran and Sam.
So halt with this as well.
Like I would always describe that as
like the most fun I've ever had on a
hunt.
It was a good baby ever.
I don't know,
we've done a lot of stuff.
We were laughing a lot.
That's why it was like a lot of fun and
a lot of it wasn't a hardship.
Like we didn't sleep in tents.
Note we slept at Mike's House,
which is great.
And then it was a lot of hiking and
stuff and you know,
it wasn't successful until like the very
last days and you shot a moose in the
celebration was fantastic.
We had a good time.
We had a great sense.
Super hammered the last night.
Remember last night,
what were you drinking?
Like some kind of spiced rum or some
kind?
I don't know.
It got it got real.
It's well when you're drunk and you're
drunk in the middle of nowhere and
there's wolves everywhere.
It's a different kind of draw.
Remember we remember,
remember that we went and we shot your
bull,
right?
And,
but then we took the heart and the
liver.
Yep.
We started drinking heavily and you were
up there to cook and liver and onions
cooking up a giant moose heart.
So we had like the fuel of organs of an
animal you just killed,
like it's Kinda like trash bag,
Canadian rum.
That was terrible.
Yeah.
And that's where the party did,
but it worked.
It worked a real good.
I
don't know what's good rum or bad room
at all.
To me,
I kind of get good whiskey now.
I understand whiskey sort of,
but be an Irish.
It's just like it's all just goes in,
gets in there and then it just does what
it does when it's in there.
Yeah.
Once the part is begun.
Like here's what I don't get Tequila.
Good Tequila.
Every Tequila average,
right?
I go like this.
What about that George Clooney,
Tequila,
Tequila Jamie,
Jamie.
You'll know.
Well listen,
I'll tell you what sounds like a,
like a fancy George Clooney.
Tequila can suck a dick because ron
white's got his own Tequila.
Numero won sarcastic Tequila.
It's just,
that's what he calls it.
Numeral one tomorrow.
One Tequila.
I think that's what it's called,
right?
Number one,
or is it number one?
Number one.
Number one,
George Clooney wasn't good enough at
everything else and all handsome and
wonderful.
He made a Tequila company and like did
it right.
If you listen to the the origin story of
it,
they did it right.
Well,
I'm looking at the company.
There's another one,
Ron White.
No,
that I wanted shit to.
Ron's is good shit,
but I think George Clooney has got
enough money so fuck him,
but I think he sold it for millions and
billions of dollars.
Yeah.
See what happened is he got married and
he realized it wasn't.
I'm going to have some money on the side
in case the shit hits the rocks.
What do I like to do?
And I'm a little bit bored and not
feeling it.
Tequila.
Yeah.
Every man who has ever heard an awful
divorce story,
no matter how good it's going,
every awful divorce started with I do.
They all started with idea.
They all started with good intentions.
You,
you're amazing and good intentions
started with good times,
man.
How we'll say it again,
I won't say the name of the person
because it would just be me and not
knock it.
There was a fellow that I like.
I knew in my younger years that got
married and I was in the wedding party,
so she got there.
She got there.
Let's weed.
It's very dangerous.
Dangerous for you.
If you're living in Montana,
you can't handle this yet.
No,
no,
no.
It's not legal there.
They made it illegal medical.
They made medical legal.
Then they voted it out.
Fucking savages go with a male.
They made medical legal and they had
dispensaries and then they voted the
dispensary's out.
When I was in Bozeman last time I was
there,
they were.
They were shutting down the doors of the
dispensary's.
You're living in the golden land here.
Yeah,
but you know what?
I hesitate to say this,
but it's probably for the best.
Just to keep people like me were in a
safe space.
It's just me and you were in the trust
tree.
Ring the nest.
Bozeman is so special.
It's such a cool little town we
shouldn't be talking about.
I shouldn't be telling people how great
it is,
so terrible place.
Bears will eat you alive.
They really in the streets there in the
streets,
but the good thing is the dumb people
get eaten by bears.
That's true.
Like people turn up missing like some
assholes deals.
Lawn mowers.
He'll just turn up missing visit.
He'll be out there and we've gone bear
just forest.
Yeah.
They get cocky and you know people that
just make it to live to be 100 and la
they get eaten
when only 35.
That's we'll place.
Yeah,
but that's in the summer.
Don't give a fuck.
I was there in the winter.
It's like it's like that.
But White.
Yeah.
You ever seen the show?
Game of thrones in the winter.
It's like white walkers when there's a
large ice wall.
When did you move?
We just.
My family just moved there.
We just moved into our brand new home
about three weeks ago there.
Mr Rogen,
but you were there before.
Were you renting?
I was renting.
Living Out of A.
I lived out of a storage unit for a
time.
I had heard about this rumor,
there was a rumor,
wild Bento,
Brian Brian lives in storage in the
storage unit and said it was a nice
storage unit.
Shout out to the airport in north
storage.
You just sleeping there.
Oh,
well did you get a gym membership or
something?
Listen,
airport,
north storage.
It's time for me to tell the truth.
Oh my God,
I can't believe you're coming clean with
them.
I'm coming and clean.
I did sleep in there some nights I slept
in a storage unit because there are laws
against that.
I probably.
It's probably like in the contract when
you sign not to do that.
Really?
I did it anyway.
What do you think will happen to you?
They would probably be out of the
storage unit and get a hotel.
You fucking Weirdo you fucking loser,
but I just did that,
you know,
as a sacrifice for my family.
We're building the house I needed to be
where my job was.
Plus you camp out there.
We can't put this beautiful man.
It's beautiful.
And in Bozeman is so popular that time
of year that it's hard to.
Oh,
that's right.
Yeah,
it's hard to find a place to stay for a
short period of time,
begin b's and all that stuff.
That ain't really going down.
Amazing.
Airbnb,
they just figured out a way to like rent
houses on make money when no one's
there.
Like Hey,
I'm good.
How did nobody ever figured that out
before?
It's Kinda crazy.
So there's a lot of these technology
companies like learn.
We do in that before uber is a great one
too.
I was coming home the other night and
there was five lifts behind me so you
know,
lyft is different because they have that
weird thing on the dash,
that little light it and it was like I
was being chased by these purple robots.
I was like,
what the fuck is this?
This is strange.
I was going to ask if you had the
storage,
the big storage unit story Fernandez.
You guys were just talking about that.
No,
this big storage unit story.
Yeah.
You remember like just to show that was
on the storage wars,
whatever.
Oh yeah.
The guy that was responsible for selling
them to people sold one to a guy for
$500 and inside was a safe that had
seven point $5,000,000
in cash in it.
Look at that guy.
Was this one that,
you know,
it wasn't on the show.
It just happened recently,
so the guy that bought it,
but I actually was contacted by lawyers
from the people who owned it and he made
a deal with them.
What's the deal?
Like a million or something like that.
I gave the the Joe do you want to go
into a business where storage wars?
Yeah,
guy's face.
We get the fuck.
I say this lady is happy dumb.
You have to feel.
You have a whole show about people
finding things in storage units.
You sell a storage unit and it's got
$7,000,000
in seven and a half,
seven and a half million dollars.
Still though the dude gets to keep a
million.
How does that work though,
is in his storage unit.
How would he chose that kind of fuck
off?
Where do you go?
Someone lost $7,000,000.
Well,
for gonna come after you.
How dirty is that money.
Exactly.
Somebody must be safe and it wasn't just
the safe only in the storage unit.
Oh,
that's got to be something bad and get
that handsome dude.
That was in the beginning of ozarks at
handsome Mexican dude.
Straight up murder.
He's going to come visit you.
Hello man.
Yeah,
that guy was my favorite.
I was so sad when they spoiler alert.
So sad when they killed him.
Like the dude from breaking bad.
That comes around he twins.
But did you see Ozark?
You ever see Ozark?
I watched like the first couple episodes
and I fucked it up for you.
Yeah,
because it was a pivotal moment and I
just gave voice to many.
There's so many shows though.
There are so many shows,
but that's a damn good one.
Is it good?
That is a damn good show.
What's the guy?
The Guy who stars in it.
Jason Bateman Bateman.
He's excellent in the woman.
Laura Linney Linney.
She's amazing.
The family's amazing kids.
Amazing.
It's fucking show,
man.
It's a show.
It's dope.
You get sucked in and that Netflix lets
you watch them all like,
are you ready?
Listen,
let me ask you a question.
I asked.
A lot of people is not set to set up a
Christmas party and I got with a bunch
of hunters and I got a couple of like
the stinkeye like,
what's this guy talking to
conservatives?
I don't know,
but if that maybe I'm just weird.
Have you ever seen the movie the
greatest showman?
Oh,
is that the,
um,
the musical?
It is.
I've been forced to watch segments of
that with my wife and children.
It is fantastic.
Very good movie.
Hugh Jackman's in angel.
He's an angel and Australian Angel.
He is.
He sent down here to save us.
Save us.
You ever seen him dance and sing?
He's magical.
I'm a hunter.
I got a hunting podcast.
But I'm telling you,
you're a manly man.
Look at that beard.
Yeah,
we get this thing,
but I love that movie.
It's a great movie.
I listened to it on the Pandora,
the greatest showman channel,
and I sing the tune.
Listen to my favorite comedy on TV is
the unbreakable Kimmy Schmidt.
I'm okay.
So I can't be talking about man liftings
or non mainly.
Thanks.
Hugh Jackman,
perform announced world tour set to
perform the greatest showman songs.
He's going to just sing.
Look at him,
look at him.
Wow Man.
Show gorgeous man.
He's just.
I mean it's unbelievable.
Unbelievable.
But yeah,
I get,
I get made fun of for this.
My.
Of course my son likes it.
My wife likes it,
but I enjoy.
I get into like your son.
How old is he?
He's two.
He doesn't know anybody,
but he just liked the music.
He just happening.
Something's going on.
Yeah,
that there's some on the TV.
He's not like a crazy.
He's not writing that critique APP,
but if you put it on Dora the explorer
and then you switched it over to that
bullshit.
He believes this fucking guy dancing.
No,
he'll be Dora.
Dora.
Yeah.
Listen,
I think that I watched like if you watch
things like game of thrones where
they're burning children.
Yeah.
And like it's entertaining,
but sometimes I need a break.
I'd like to watch a man dance around and
sing for a woman,
whatever.
It don't matter.
Those those shows can get dark where you
like,
what am I doing to myself,
you know,
like narcos.
Oh yeah.
And they would just go into a
fucking nightclub and gun people down.
Just sitting there watching like women
and children get smoked in it.
It's what's the other show with Anthony
Hopkins on HBO.
What's that?
The robots.
Oh,
westworld.
The same way they're shooting kids on
there though.
The kids a robot.
We can just pass that one right in the
face.
Dark.
So every once in a while you need to
sprinkle a little bit of musical in your
life,
I believe.
Yeah.
What is that do you think?
And here's come coming from a person
that's been on a bunch of life changing
experiences and I know you have,
I want to talk to you about some of
them.
Yes.
Especially the one in Nepal where you
almost died and you saw children in
wolves,
babies.
We talked about that on the last
podcast,
but it's probably,
it would be worth revisiting.
Um,
what do you think this is like why?
Why are we so obsessed with life or
death drama that's artificial?
Well,
you see it like in the,
in the,
in the show Westworld,
they talk about like it being a game
that being this game of excess,
like what can I do in my real life?
So when you watch TV and you watch
murdering and you watched this,
this evil thing come to life,
you're just,
you're,
it's,
it really is something that you can be
transported,
can't do that in your regular life.
Fruits for sure.
With Westworld,
what you're getting is basically a real
live version that red dead redemption.
Yes.
Right.
So when you,
when you play that,
we were talking about the other day,
how this guy got in trouble because they
have all these things in the game that
you can do to people.
And this guy like ty this hook her up,
threw her off a cliff and shit and you
can start,
you can do whatever you want.
But they were filming this stuff and
putting it on youtube.
And then youtube would get mad and
youtube pulled them off.
But then people are like,
well,
wait a minute though,
why?
How come you can just do it?
Like why did you have that in the game?
But when my dad was my age 30,
40 years ago,
there would,
they would never have ever does nothing
done anything like game of thrones or
Westworld?
Never ever.
In fact,
there was a westworld and it wasn't
anywhere near like it is.
You'll be modern day.
Good moving.
Yeah.
But I think we've just stretched out the
limits to which we're willing to
explore,
like really terrible and evil things for
entertainment.
We've definitely changed what we're
willing to accept and where the bar is
in terms of quality,
the bars through the roof,
through the roof.
It's immersive to the point where you
can't even can't even explain what
you're experiencing when you're watching
these shows.
Yeah.
So like if you go and you see some great
comedy from the 19 nineties,
like you see watch a Dave Chappelle and
Chris rock specials in the nineties that
holds up 100 percent and Seinfeld it
gives up.
But what I'm saying is like if that was
out today,
it would be a 100 percent standup
special prayer.
Be Like,
Oh,
you see the new Chris Rock's bigger and
blacker.
It's fucking amazing.
But if you tried to put some bullshit
ass 19 nineties TV show on,
on Netflix,
if you to like finagle some CSI Miami
type shit.
You know what I mean?
Something.
Some nonsense.
I don't know if CSI Miami,
is that even a show?
Is that a real sharp?
There's a CSI Miami.
There is.
There's several.
There's many CSI I guessed,
but we'd like to order law and order.
There's so many of those.
But we've expanded our willingness to
like explore things that are.
I mean,
game of thrones for example,
is one of the best shows ever created in
my opinion for sure.
But it explores some unthinkable thing.
Awful things.
Well,
it's the whole show.
Spoiler alert is around a brother and
sister were fucked and had a whole
family.
Yeah.
So it explore these,
these things that in we would never even
touch upon in our media in the fifties,
sixties,
the seventies.
We be touched upon those things in a way
that we do now.
No,
not only that,
but here's the thing.
Law and order's not a bad show.
Like if you watch it,
you'll be entertained.
So what happened?
Why?
Why do we go not good enough?
Like what?
What was it was it was the question,
did they go not good enough or is it
like like porn?
Like if you watch porn,
okay.
And you watch some porn from the 19
eighties and then you flipped through
like youporn.
Not that I would ever do that,
but if you did do that and looked at all
the different categories,
you'd be like,
what the fuck happened?
Yeah.
Like why are people.
Why has gagging something people are
looking for?
It's not an accident
category.
We've expanded our ability to conceive
of things.
Yes.
In immediate space where we can create,
you can create dragons that,
that breathe ice.
You can create.
There's,
there's things you can be transported,
like,
listen,
this isn't real so I can.
I can do this,
right?
I can have this scene of of rape or
infidelity or are incest that seems
appropriate to me only in this fantasy
world,
man.
Sometimes I get down on that stuff.
I watch enough of it.
You're just like,
I need a musical.
I need to be inspired.
That life is grand and that's how I feel
about them and sometimes it comes across
and like this dude washes musicals,
but I.
I do for a little bit of a
right.
Something's wrong with it.
What I'm weirded out about is this
natural human inclination towards
progression in everything good or bad is
that things just keep ramping up
well,
but we're progressing with our
storylines for like humanity in a weird
way in media,
but we're also like suppressing a lot of
our.
We're trying to suppress through social
justice a lot of the same thing,
right?
Well,
some people are,
but I think it's a small,
very vocal minority.
I think in reality there's,
the vast majority of people find out
about said suppression are upset by it
and they're like,
what in the fuck are you talking about
this safe spaces and all this nonsense?
Most people that hear that stuff,
we're going,
oh,
this is just nonsense by a few,
like really loud,
devastated even on my podcast.
It's something as
serious as hunting is because you're
killing stuff like that's going out into
the world and taking plucking something
that you didn't put.
They're taking it away,
but I think the core of what I think you
do well and what I think others should
try to do is ask why?
Why are we willing to.
Why is game of thrones the most watched
show that's on right?
Why?
Why,
why?
I can't answer that question,
but it's a conversation because it's.
If it's so fictitious,
right?
It's so obviously fiction.
You're living in this fictional world.
You have fictional white walkers,
you have dragons,
he have people that can survive in fire,
parallels to real life and then these,
these ridiculous fantasies,
but then these parallels to real life
that that travel along the same path and
like you don't get to choose between the
dragons and the incest both there at the
same time.
I think it fulfills a lot of like base
needs,
but it does.
So in this way,
that's obviously false.
Yeah.
So like why are superheroes so huge to
us?
If you stop and think about the number
of blockbusters that are superhero
movies that are comic book movies are
coming out like once every couple of
months now.
Crazy that that was a rare beast when I
was at.
Yes,
when I was a kid,
there's a hulk movie.
I would've jumped for joy.
It was no Goddamn Spiderman movie when I
was a kid.
There was a TV show and it sucked.
Okay.
It was a God damn cartoon TV show,
Spiderman,
Spiderman does whatever.
Spider spins a web size,
catches thieves just like flies couch.
There comes a spider man.
It was terrible.
And I used to get up early to watch it
because I was a huge comic book.
You've watched the Lou Ferrigno Hulk,
right?
Fuck yeah,
I watched it.
That was a little bit.
I mean like you watch the Batman Adam
West.
Yeah.
You watch him now and you're like,
what is happening?
So they came out with Superman.
He was like the first movies that.
What is the Spiderman TV show?
Wow.
That's another TV show guy in the back
of the second in the background doing
who's that guy?
You don't look.
You don't do anything good.
It's got a wooden stick.
He needs to know those shits.
Spiderman can shoot webs out of his
hands and that wouldn't sticks.
Probably not going to do much.
Then then spiderman sort of changes
ability,
right?
Because it used to be able to do like
now he could just basically fly.
I mean just hurls himself through the
air and sticks to buildings,
you know?
He used to be a little harder to swing
around back because like,
let me drop my backpack full of
textbooks,
get to it.
But he's.
That was,
there was no spiderman movies when I was
kid and there was a superman movie and
the superman movie beget the Batman
Movie Batman movie came out.
Michael Keaton was a big,
big success.
People are shocked at Michael Keaton was
Batman,
but it worked.
Was that like Danny Devito was the
penguin?
Yeah.
Everybody got a shot at Batman was one
of those things.
If you were Batman,
you must be the it guy towards clooney.
George Clooney was Batman,
Christian Bale's,
Batman Arnold Schwarzenegger was Mr.
Freeze.
But they got to Ben Affleck and no
player.
Whoa.
Isn't that funny?
Like that's real.
Like the amount of people that will see
you as Batman.
It's whether or not they really believe
it.
They like Christian Bale.
I believe that God could be Batman,
but Michael Keaton for a longest time
was Batman.
Yes,
but see,
he started it off.
See that the difference between Michael
Keaton is there was no one before him
other than Bruce Wayne,
and he was the first dark real Batman.
I forgot about val kilmer.
Goddammit.
Val kilmer was fucking Batman.
Talented human being.
Val kilmer.
He's a beast at him as a doc holiday.
Oh,
what's this?
What's the name of that movie?
Tombstone?
Tombstone.
God Damn.
That's one of the best.
He was spooked students ever.
He was believable.
That was a.
That was a straight up murder.
I still the most quoted,
but see,
nobody will think back on Ben Affleck's
career and be like,
he was Batman.
It's not just that he's done some good
move.
Yeah,
but he's also.
He always says there's nothing around
his career that he.
He must feel like,
oh man,
if this goes bad,
it's going to ruin me.
He's done so many great things.
He's a very good actor.
Don't get me wrong,
but what is it about him?
Is he too handsome?
No,
because val kilmer is gorgeous.
All those folks were very handsome.
Gigli him and Jennifer Lopez is that.
It was a tough time.
She just say Gigli Gigli.
I think it was really whatever the fuck
it is.
Whatever the fuck it is.
They look.
Not everybody should get that kind of
pussy.
It's just.
It shouldn't be on your diet.
It's too rich for you.
Some people get diabetes,
right?
They need to lay off the sugar.
Everybody's got different tolerance cake
every morning.
Jennifer Lopez,
obviously,
besides being beautiful and a body like
some sort of a test tube person,
some lab created super freak.
Obviously she knows how to throw that
thing.
She knows how to throw that thing.
I mean,
it'd be hard to.
It would be hard to argue with that
fact.
Yeah,
that's some Goddamn Nolan.
Ryan Pussy Shit.
Together.
I am not unaware of what you're talking
about.
I love the fact that those things go so
hard to go so hard and then they fizzle
out.
They just.
You know what it's like.
It's like having a like a pinto with a
fucking corvette,
Zr one engine stuff.
Don't stomp on the gas on the highway
and there's no structure to it,
but listen to design.
Those wheels are not designed for that
relationship.
Is that why you live in Hollywood?
You're telling me.
Is that why these Hollywood
relationships always like become huge
and then go away?
Sometimes they do.
Sometimes they work.
I live in Montana.
Here's my thing.
This Alex Rodriguez guy that she's with
super athlete smashes it.
Obviously it seems to be working.
They've been together for a long time.
How long have they been together though?
Months from six weeks.
When she was with that little bit of the
singer.
She got mad.
He was at the UFC that one time,
remember?
Oh,
that's right.
She left.
Which one was that?
That was the dancer.
Can I take.
Can we take a a quick.
This is a like a kind of a PSA,
public service announcement.
Can we take a hard left of Jennifer
Lopez and get ourselves over to Kanye
West real quick?
Yeah,
we can,
but look at that.
Alex Rodrigues.
Okay.
Take a look at that man.
Super Athlete.
Probably got a dick.
Like a Goddamn Baseball Bat,
right?
Anybody that has that many buttons.
Let's look at those top buttons coming
down sides of his fist,
the size of that guys.
Paul,
he said two plus $200.
Million contract.
So he's.
He's just gotten $400,000,000
on our giant hot super athlete.
Of course it's going to work.
It's going to smash it together.
Let's talk about hunting.
He knows that guy knows how to keep it
together.
Right?
That guy knows he knows how to play when
the ball's coming his way,
he smashes that fucking thing.
I think Jennifer Lopez is not tolerating
any losers in her life at this point.
Left.
She's had a few,
but that's all I look at.
That guy.
Yeah,
there you go.
Super Athlete.
Big giant Hanson.
I'm a big sports fan.
I came up when he was just.
He was.
It was a god,
a baseball guy.
They seem to get along together.
Seed.
That makes sense to me.
Just like it made sense with val.
Kilmer was Batman tends to me,
but when Ben Affleck was Ben Affleck,
I don't know how his relationship was
with her.
I don't know.
Maybe it was great.
It seemed like it was a tumultuous,
but I'm not.
I'm just observing.
What do I know?
Nobody knows,
but there's some people where you.
You need to have an online vote for this
person that definitely the people will
tell you they would not have voted.
I do not believe they would have voted
for Ben Affleck.
I do nonbeliever.
Here's the problem,
like the rock too big for Batman.
Here's why.
Because everybody will be like,
oh,
it's you.
The Rock.
You're wearing a fucking bat suit is
that they wish they could do that.
They can make it funny and be like,
yeah,
are you in the movie?
They can make it funny,
but yeah.
Is this the rock or the rock?
He could never be superman.
Takes his fucking glasses off.
You're like,
you're still a giant dude.
The last time doesn't work for the
regular size,
but that's how it works.
The last guy that was the superman was
an.
It was an unknown.
Henry a superman.
They ran out.
They ran out of the.
Well,
the well's dry.
It's like if they try to make another
hawk,
people know enough.
You've had eight hawks.
They're going to keep making them
through.
They're going to make 100 more star wars
in the next five years and you're going
to have to sit through like Han Solo.
The pre,
pre preschool.
The Cow.
Can they do that?
That doesn't make any sense because
Harrison Ford was Han Solo when Han Solo
was young.
Oh yeah.
We can't just do that.
They just came out with the Han Solo
movie to reel back on that because that
last one didn't do so hot.
Yeah.
They need to ask me to ask Joe.
I'm here for you.
George Lucas.
Oh,
now bathing and money.
He's flying back in a warm wet money.
He just forgot to listen to the podcast.
He just,
he just gets touched all day.
What was going to be coming out or start
like Adam
to see?
Oh,
they're making them.
They ran out of superheroes.
Superman in the background.
That's superman in the background.
See,
it's in the DC universe.
There is in back.
They ran up.
He looks good.
Yeah,
but as long as they don't try to make
him superman.
Is he a bad guy?
Jamie?
Is he a bad guy or a good guy?
Honestly,
I've never heard of this character.
I,
I've no idea where he fits in the.
I remember when Netflix came out with
Luke cage,
I was like,
wow,
that's an obscure one.
That was a good one though,
but the Black Panther was good at the
Black Panthers.
Good.
It's a great movie.
Yeah,
it's amazing.
It took so long and we go black panther
movie racist took so long and it was a
giant smash hit.
There you go.
White people get it together.
No comment.
Ben Obrian in the conservative world has
to be careful.
This podcast could sink a ship on pro
nuance.
Yeah.
How'd you come up with a shirt pro
nuance?
I listened.
I think the way that I came up with it
is because in the,
in the hunting world,
there is this,
speaking of conservative,
there's this like there's the
conservative traditional district.
Yeah.
And there's the more progressive folks
that you have met and been around.
You've been around both but be around
both that are more environmentalist,
more public lands,
more access.
Right.
Um,
so there's kind of like to,
of course there's always two sides of
politics,
but there's,
in this case,
two distinct sides,
right.
And the line kind of gets drawn around
one a little bit around guns,
but also a little bit around the
environment.
So part of the biggest issue in politics
for a hunter angler right now is like,
I really like guns.
I like the second amendment.
I dig what's going on there.
I'd like to support that.
But what I also like is healthy
ecosystems and environment and I don't
know,
like habitat for wild game to live and
public lands and access.
Well,
it just so happens that a lot of the a
plus rated politicians for the NRA are
like f minus or a plus rated in
protecting wildlife and wild lands and a
lot of that's around extraction and
different things like that,
but extraction of minerals and oil and
natural reason for valuable lands.
Right.
So then change the way these lands are
scheduled.
Like what?
What it's under?
Yeah.
I mean there was a lot of around
monuments.
Of course that was one big one,
but it's just around like the general
basis of even as a hunter but all
Americans.
But as a hunter I'm faced with like I
love wildlife,
I love wild places,
clean water,
clean land,
I'm all for that.
That's a huge part of what I believe in,
but I also believe in the second
amendment.
I believe in my right to defend my
family.
I believe in my rights to own firearms
and to do that.
So I believe in those two things,
but because our politics are the way
they are,
it doesn't leave room for those two
beliefs.
When I'm at at the voting booth,
sometimes not all the time,
something is hardly leaves room for
those beliefs in normal conversations
with people,
unless you absolutely know that the
person's going to be objective and as
your shirt says pro nuance this,
the idea that you you shouldn't be able
to defend your family is where it gets
crazy.
Yeah.
It doesn't get crazy that you want to be
able to defend your family.
Like why do these
movies all have robberies and break ins
and bad guys?
Well,
why did you visit a real things?
That's a real thing.
So the idea that you should just be a
sitting duck because there's so many
crazy fucks out there that want to shoot
up schools and go on mass shootings that
somehow or another,
your being conflated with them year
could be being confused with them or
categorized with them.
Like how?
How has that that these are different
things.
They both involve guns.
They are there things.
It's like the insole that drove all of
those people in Toronto.
Member that.
Yep.
You know what?
If that keeps happening,
that's happened many times.
You've seen people kill people with cars
over the last few years.
It's been like
four or five big events.
Are they mutually exclusive?
Like I want to be able to defend my
family and own firearms and have that
freedom.
That's a big part of this country,
but I also don't want people to die.
Exactly.
Mass shootings.
I don't want that.
I want on the other side of the coin
with you when it comes to environmental
issues and around hunting,
public lands and things of that nature.
I want coal miners to have jobs.
I want people that work in an extraction
industries to have an opportunity to
work and live in and do what they need
to do,
but I also want to protect our
ecosystems at all costs because you
can't replace that shit.
Right.
And there's gotTa be other jobs out
there.
If the government put its resources
instead to propping up old ways of doing
business that pollute the environment
versus new ways of doing business with
government programs,
that's entirely possible.
Yeah.
There are certainly reasonable and
healthy ways to mine copper ore or
waste.
I don't know.
There is.
I mean,
there's responsible ways to do that,
but at what?
At what cost?
You're still,
you're still extracting,
like you're still doing something,
do it.
You're still changing the natural
environment there.
Yeah.
Someone was trying to make that argument
with fracking with me.
I was talking to them about that.
Is it Josh Fox's documentary?
What is he?
He was on the podcast,
the something fracking nation.
What was his,
uh,
he made a,
it was a very good documentary and it
was when I had him on the podcast,
it was interesting because he seemed
like he had been attacked a lot for it
and even misunderstood,
like some of the questions I was asking
that maybe they were coming from me and
I was saying,
no,
this is just like,
what was it called?
Fragmentation.
What does it gasland that's it.
Oh yes.
Okay.
It's,
um,
it's disturbing.
You're watching some aspects of it,
like when were wedding lighting their
water on fire and then someone tried to
say,
oh,
there's some places where you've always
been able to let your water on fire.
I was like,
okay,
did.
Okay.
Erica tradition of lighting a real
argument that someone said that that's
not really from fracking,
and I said,
okay,
these people said that there was no
lighting.
The water on fire.
Then people started fracking.
The water smell like shit.
They started lighting a fire though.
You're saying those are connected.
Over the years,
Joe,
we've been able to light their water on
fire for for a number of reasons,
but fourth of July
I would think to be confident about that
and I'm not confident about it,
but to be confident about what that guy
said to me when he was saying that,
it's always been like that.
You would have to have done massive
research.
You would have to have spent time there.
You would have to been working either
directly or indirectly with the
scientists that are collecting the data.
You'd have to get it from them.
You'd have to know.
You'd have to see it.
You'd have to make sure or you have to
be a person who is not interested in the
actual truth.
They just have an idea that they want to
push through and this is a weird thing
with certain right wing folks.
There's a weird thing they want to push
through that business is good and
environmentalists are all pussies and
hippies and Weirdos and losers and these
things don't jive in the world of
someone who actually loves and
appreciates the actual earth.
Of course,
man,
weird,
but
there is no way that anyone could argue,
right?
There's,
there's in the hunting world are sort of
like access and public land and all
these things become a big deal,
but you can define access and a ton of
different ways.
To me,
accessible to me,
access could be I like wilderness or to
the only way you can access it,
his own foot via,
via trail head.
Someone else might say access to me is
uh,
elderly folks or disabled folks fail and
to get on into a car and drive through a
road and public land or,
or get into an atv and drive.
And so politics being what they are.
Politicians take this term of access.
It happened around national monuments.
They take one side,
said the president of stealing your
land,
and the other side says,
the president is giving back your land.
Somebody,
they're either,
both sides are full of shit or one of
them is.
I remember when this came up,
Patagonia,
which is a giant company and doors had a
big ad on the Internet that said,
the president,
just so your land,
and then I heard Rinella talk about and
he said this is,
I'm going to paraphrase,
but he basically said,
if you say that the presence until your
land,
you're not being careful with your
words.
Yes.
And you're not being,
you're being inflammatory.
Yes.
You're being absolutely inflammatory
because it's not again,
that you were talking about grand
staircase,
Escalante and bears ears National
Monument bears ears being in Utah,
being explained to people what happened.
A boy.
Um,
I'll,
I'll do my best show.
Thank you Ben.
So,
so the antiquities act,
let's go back to the antiquities act to
protect the antiquities act is to
protect,
um,
culturally or socially,
emotionally,
culturally significant pieces of,
of land it all the way to the things
like the Grand Canyon.
Right?
And so spin it up to the end of,
there's a lot that I just skipped over,
but I'm going to spin it up to the end
of the Obama administration.
President
Obama used his executive power to
protect large swaths,
millions of acres around the brown bears
ears national monument to protect not
only the,
the significant places for native
Americans,
for native tribesman around bears ears,
but many millions of acres around that.
And so then it becomes the problem I
have in the y that kind of,
that tee shirt exists.
It becomes a political football throw
back and forth.
It's not at this point in time what's
best for bears ears.
What's best for that National Monument
was best for,
for it to be fairly owned,
what's best for the people,
the jobs,
the place it becomes what's best for
each side and their rhetoric.
And so president trump asked secretary,
former secretary of Interior Ryan Zinky
to review,
I think it was like 10 monuments to see
if they should be reduced based on the
productions that Obama had put put into
place.
So he reviews these 10 monuments.
He cuts out eight of them and hones in
on two places,
bears ears and grand staircase
Escalante.
They then say,
we're going to reduce the size of these
monuments.
When you say cuts out eight of them,
what do you mean by cuts out and they
review the other eight and say they're
fine.
They're good to go.
No changes necessary.
Okay.
Some would say they did that as a,
as a straw men as eight straw men to
knock them over and look at those other
two.
They said we will reduce the.
The the area that is designated as a
national monument,
and here again it comes to both sides.
They would say because the President
Obama wheel,
that is his powers corruptly to protect,
to be as an environmentalist,
to protect lands that didn't need
protected under the antiquities act
because the antiquities act does say it
should be the smallest acreage possible
to protect.
So now you get into stuff that I'm not
an expert in or around the legal jargon
and going back to things that were
written in the 19 thirties,
but we get to a point where one side
saying here is the Republicans trying to
shrink down these monuments so that they
can then go to the companies that are
can then go and lease these places for
mining,
but they can't currently do on their
protections as a national monument.
The other side is saying we're trying to
protect culturally significant lands and
these millions of acres need protected.
Then you protect for lots of reasons,
so you end up with those two sides
talking.
Now it's easy to sort of make a hype
hyperbolic,
parabolic.
I always want to say that wrong.
Cut that back with hyperbolic argument
one way or the other,
right?
Yeah.
I mean you could kind of exaggerate your
position one way or the other and it's
being done that way.
It's been done that way.
Are they drilling there now or did he
look.
Let's look that up,
but there is some leases that were that
were approved for for bears ears.
I know for sure.
See,
that's one of the things where people
talk about the president doesn't have
any real power.
There's congress understand that and
like really they have some checks and
balances,
but there's the executive orders that
can come down.
Listen,
I'm not the expert on this.
I'm sure I fumbled through some of the
details on that,
but.
But to me the bottom line is something
like that,
why I like to to live in the centers
because something like that becomes.
It becomes a thing that it becomes a pr
hit.
Yeah.
It becomes a thing that people are
throwing back there,
throwing bears ears back and forth
because at the end of Obama's
administration,
he made the designation and they've.
They repealed it or reversed it a year
later.
Right?
Or some amount of time around a year
later.
So it was only the way it was for a year
and everybody's making it.
Look,
government stole your land.
They just brought it back to exactly
where it was before,
but they did open up the possibility,
which is why Obama did in the first
place.
Yes.
They opened up the possibility for
drilling and now they did resource
extraction and that scares the shit out
of people.
So like there's,
there's,
there's two.
They're in these situations.
There always seems to be spin on both
sides and being a part of these debates
on a daily basis and being a part of
this,
like bringing in this information on a
daily basis.
It's tiresome.
You know,
you get tired,
you tired of being pandered to buy.
People are tired of having to hear that
this value system is right or this value
system is right and there's no room to
be anywhere close to the center around
this stuff.
So you just get is.
It's tiresome.
You know,
public lands are the only place where I
look at it and say,
no,
you gotta leave that to the government.
You got to lead it to the federal
government.
Don't,
don't let leave it to the states.
It's the only place.
I mean,
when I,
when I think about all the different
things,
like with the legalization of marijuana
and now they're going to legalize
silicide and apparently in Oregon
they're talking about doing that or
like,
yeah,
leave it to the states.
They should be able to vote that in.
They should be able to vote in like all
the crazy laws.
You have weird states and some states
have state taxes,
some states don't.
It's all good.
That's all good.
But when it comes to like federal land,
the problem is if these dates get into
debt and this is what people need to
understand,
they can sell it off.
Yeah,
so Utah is in debt.
Let's just.
I'm just not picking on Youtube,
but if they just for some reason,
they wind up in debt which states do all
the time and then they sell off a giant
chunk of land to some oil company.
Now you can't camp there anymore.
You can and by the way,
that's your fucking land and not pay
taxes.
UTAH.
That's your land.
You live in Arizona,
you live in Florida.
That's your land.
You live in Massachusetts.
It's yours.
That land in Utah is the whole fucking.
All of us.
They'll collected human race living on
North America.
Listen to this,
listen to this shit.
This is like there's a guy named Senator
Mike Lee of the Great State of Utah,
which you rightly
put that all out of these things revolve
around the Utah for some reason.
Do they want.
They have a lot of the percentage of.
It's like something that's 70 percent of
their acreage is,
is controlled by the federal government.
That's why.
Plus Mormons.
Let me.
I'll take the first point.
You take got that.
So Senator Mike Lee Comes out and says,
right,
this is like the perfect,
the perfect way to spend this type of
thing.
He starts,
he calls back to and Senator Orrin Hatch
from Utah has also done this call back
to like the sagebrush rebellion and
things like that calling back saying
that wilderness is akin to the European
aristocracy because only a certain few
can go there because you have to have
two working legs that can get you up
into wilderness.
Part of the basis of a speech he gave,
and it is given it several times,
is that public land and wilderness
specifically is is akin to the the
European aristocracy because only
certain folks can go there.
If you would open up access cut roads
through it,
then it would be for everyone,
so then it gets back to the semantics in
the spin and the things that politicians
push forward to try to convince you.
Well there still for you,
he's right in a certain way.
What he's right in is that if you put
roads through,
anybody could go through anytime they
wanted on a car.
If they had no legs,
he can barely walk.
If they are in a wheelchair normally,
but they can drive a car.
Yeah.
They can go in deep into the woods and
they can enjoy all of the wilderness.
Sure.
The cast off that is true.
However,
did I.
it's not like there's a lot of places
that they can't also go to.
Theirs didn't go a lot of places where
they can do that.
You can go to yellowstone,
yellowstone damn gorgeous.
You just drive through that and you see
all the trees and the animals and
yellowstone is a wonderful proxy for
going outside.
Yeah.
It's an introduction to what it is
without really being in it.
Yeah.
It's like a zoo that's free range is
exactly what it is.
I live right.
I live an hour from there and I've taken
my family there and it just feels like.
I used to feel like,
oh man,
this is an elicit place.
As somebody who's gone into the
Wilderness and tackle these big
challenges and hiked around and crazy
places this yellowstone,
it's like,
Eh,
it makes me feel uncomfortable.
Then I.
Somebody said to me,
I feel like it was this guy named cody
rich who has a podcast called the rich
outdoors.
He said to me,
it's like,
it's like it's.
I'm an ambassador for real wilderness.
It's like a way to present to people
that this thing exists without them
having to actually strap on a pack,
get some tracking poles and hike miles
up into the wilderness.
This is part of the problem whenever
you're talking about the wilderness is
so few people go to it.
It's like if we were talking about the
surface of Mars with the people that
create the rover,
well,
you know how the surface of Mars is it
gums up the wheels,
it's read Stephen read how many people
are going to Mars,
how many people are really going into
the wilderness?
Yeah,
I mean not that many.
It's more people going to the wilderness
than Mars.
But I've always said like the,
the public lands movement in and I'm
definitely part of it.
Um,
I feel like I could probably represented
the monument things better,
but like I,
I'm definitely part of it.
It,
it's,
it's scary and a little in a lot of ways
because people can say like,
keep it public man and keep it public.
That's just like apple pie and bald
eagles and freedom.
It's an idea that we all pay into a
thing.
We all own.
Anybody can go there.
It's super easy to get on that train.
It is real easy to get on that train and
lose your critical thought around what,
what is the idea of wilderness?
I mean,
because when I think of my hunting now,
like when you first went hunting like
five or six years ago,
you would asked me this question.
I would have given you a whole different
thing.
What would you have said that?
I don't know what I would've said that,
but not this answer.
I might've said like,
well,
you fairly youngish man.
I'm only growing in 30 1:33.
Oh,
you're beautiful person.
Look at you.
I love you too.
Perfect complexion.
Look at you.
All your cells are firing correctly.
The liver spots.
Yet this whiskey is really good stuff.
I'm Irish.
I'm so.
What do you think you would have called
it then?
So what I probably would have said like
when we first went hunting and NBC
together from Moose,
what I probably would've said would've
been around,
it would have been less value based and
more like I do it because my dad did it.
I do it because it connects me to my
dad.
Like my dad and my family.
My people.
I do it because humanity did it.
We talked,
we filmed a video.
Remember sitting on the thing,
we talked a lot about our humanity,
right?
Like the drawing back to the history of
time when the hunter was exalted in a
tribe of people was the only way to get
me.
It was the only way to get meat.
So your skills that you acquired as a
hunter made you important to the
culture,
the society,
the everyday life.
I would have probably called back to
that.
Not that I would say that's wrong now,
but what I've come to find out over some
other years of,
of hunting and a lot of places is that I
think my hunting is more about healthy
ecosystems now than it is about anything
else.
I think all of my efforts should be
around clean water,
clean air,
places that we can go and explore and
what that brings to our world that
brings more wildlife,
that brings places for my son to go and
experience these things.
And so I've changed over.
There's a very short time and the way
that I do it well,
the more you experienced the wilderness
and then go back to the city and then go
back to the wilderness,
the more you realize how special it is
out there in the mall more you realize
when like today I'm a.
When I'm flying in a helicopter over la
with my good friend Bill Burr,
and as he was taking me up,
I was looking at all this development.
We were talking about all these
apartment complexes that are being
developed and he's like,
yeah.
He goes,
you really see it when you're up here in
the air because you see where there was
nothing.
And then like a couple of weeks later
it'll be flat now and then a couple of
weeks later they start construction and
you realize like,
oh,
this is how it spreads and that this is
just something that people do.
And if you don't put a star,
put a line,
you know,
draw a line.
We're going to keep going.
We're going to make our way across the
country.
And I've heard that argument from people
that don't go to the wilderness,
like Luco mature of the unit.
We don't overpopulated.
Luke home went to the United States,
has no one living in it.
Flyover who looked down at all the
places that don't have cities and don't
have roads,
don't have houses like.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
For now.
You know that none of this shit was here
years ago.
Cloud.
We plowed ground to play the corn.
So you could have the things you have
well flyover.
No.
Team 19,
you know,
fly over 100,
200 years ago.
Bitch.
There was nothing here.
Wilbur Wright norvell.
Come on,
see what you saw.
But yeah,
if you get just go 300 years,
you have nothing.
You have zero things.
Yeah.
Well that's.
I think there's some perspective and I
think hunting has a lot going forward
around the fact that has urbanization
happens.
You know,
as jobs being for me,
like as jobs become more prevalent in
urban places and people have to travel
from wherever they're growing up to,
to these urban places in live so removed
from wilderness.
So removed from sustainability,
um,
I think for a long time because hunting
peaked in 1982,
there was like 17 point 5 million
hunters around that year because of
Ronald Reagan was president.
He was president.
I'm,
listen,
I wasn't even alive so let's not,
let's not do that shit.
I don't know.
Um,
but like post World War II,
there was a rise in the modern hunter
mountain sport hunter,
however you would describe it.
There's that,
there's this rise in 1982 and then a
precipitous fall right from there until
2016 was around 11 million hunters in
this country.
It's just a drop.
It's a big drop in Iowa.
I always say that like the three things
that I think happened or urbanization.
So people are getting removed from their
getting moved away from having hunting
in their lives on a daily basis.
Not that they're anti hunting in any
way,
they're just getting removed from,
from that thing,
getting your meat on your own.
They're removed from that.
And a lot of times you removed from like
gardening and other types of shore
sustainable use things.
The other thing is Disney,
like Walt Disney's a nice man,
but Bambi was not a good thing for our
collective psyche around hunting,
not just Bambi,
but essentially all cartoons involving
animals to animals.
Who your friends,
even predators,
like Yogi was your friend.
He was your friend.
He wore a tie bear attack and he had a
hat on.
He was at a picnic basket and you wanted
your picnic,
Jamie.
Look up.
There was a guy,
there was a dude.
I'm recently.
He was caught poaching in Missouri and
the judge said that he had to,
um,
watch Bambi once a month during his
entire sentence.
Why?
It's if you can find that that is real,
that just needs a reality show.
I kind of know what to do,
honey.
I know to do.
We'll make.
It was Bambi he posted and dear.
This is the guy like the whole other was
like a whole family.
Guys here we're in like a poaching ring
or something.
I read this on the way over here.
Um,
here it is,
dear poacher sentence to watch Bambi
every month during the year.
Missouri jail.
Yeah.
This might be a judge that's like
looking for a little,
nearly killed hundreds of deer sometimes
taking over their heads and leaving the
rest to rot and fields.
Kate,
how about you keep that guy in jail for
more than a year.
There it is.
Look at them.
David Barry Jr.
Fucking dork has been ordered to watch
one thing,
man.
If that guy was kiLling them because he
was poor and he was just eating deer and
that's how he made his.
That's how he got food.
That's not the case here.
I don't care.
He chopped their heads off and just took
the head guy.
Just fuck.
Fuck anybody who does that anyway,
for anybody who just wants to shoot
something as damn delicious and massive
as a deer,
a deer could feed a family for months.
Do you understand?
OF course it could.
You understand that,
but I mean people listening or this
asshole.
Do you understand that?
This asshole who shot this fucking
thing,
hunDred deer head off you piece of shit.
I'm patricia can look forward to eating
deer and you shot it and you.
Yeah.
Anyway,
back back like walt disney,
I think like that kind of treatment of
animals as has been something that's
hurt honey.
And the third one is hunters.
I've heard themselves like that guy.
Like maybe that's poetry is way worse.
that's a poetry.
Not 100 though,
but he's a guy who hunting illegally.
Poaching is.
He's on her.
Yeah,
but like camping.
Camping illegally.
he's trespassing.
Not.
It's not the same.
Yeah,
but you're camping.
You're trespassing and camping.
CampIng,
or maybe he's.
I know you don't want to call them a
hunter.
Like you know,
like someone who who goes on stage at a
company.
Picnic is not a comedian.
Yes,
it's the same thing.
I get it.
He's still killing the animals.
Yeah,
he's killed more than me.
That it's 100.
Yeah.
I'm a hunter and he's killed more than
the fishing exposure.
that's true.
This is a piece of shit.
He is just like everything else,
man.
There's people that are good uber
drivers and there's some that'll try to
pull you under a bridge and fuck your
mouth.
This is bad people.
That's a good point to bring up.
Like is there,
is there a time like I always bring up
with hunting,
it's like,
oh,
somebody killed a giraffe or somebody,
a guy killed a family,
baboons and made and did a photo.
I saw that.
Do you see that?
It was not good.
Not good.
It's a fucking primate bro.
Yeah,
I mean there's nothing good about that
with the,
that never going to go well for you.
It's never going to go well for you.
Did he put it online?
No,
he didn't put it online is I guess the
credit that would give the guy who put
it online,
the Idaho statesman or whatever the
Idaho local favorite was the picture.
I don't know,
probably from one of the folks he sent
an email,
a mass email out to friends and
colleagues and things of like recapping.
Recapping is hunt in africa.
Like here's all the things I did and he,
I think from my reading on the guy,
the guy,
um,
and I got a lot of mutual friends with
him.
So he's a good guy.
Like you just screwed up.
Maybe they made a bad choice.
That's a tough sell.
I would say so too,
but I should put him in a cell and make
some monkey movies.
I think he knew,
like if I put this,
if I put this spin up after this planet
of the apes,
you gotta watch the mark walberg planet
the reality of baboons and I have.
I've studied the work of robert
sapolsky,
who's a guy who's been on the podcast
before and it's really pretty amazing
stuff.
What they found out about baboons,
he studied actually because he actually
studied a baboon tribe that the alpha
males died off.
They were all eating out of a poisoned
garbage patch.
There was a garbage patch to the sick
food in it and I'm just bad food.
And the alpha males who got to eat
first,
uh,
always chased her,
but they wound up dying off.
And for more than one generation,
I think it was several generations.
They became like really peaceful and
calm and they weren't the vicious
violent baboons that are the norm and
that it's really,
if you google it,
a supple ski studies baboons and I radio
lab also had a podcast about it,
which is where I first heard about it
and then I read what paul wrote about
it,
but it is unbelievably fascinating and
shows how you can have this insane
violent animal culture and then the,
the clients get removed and when the
cops get removed,
everybody chills the fuck out and it's
really,
really quite fascinating.
BuT I'm baboons for the most part.
I mean maybe he shot the nicest
prevalence ever,
but for the most part they're a bunch of
baby cunts and they'll steal your
fucking kid.
That was a two year old that you love so
dearly.
That little motherfucker be on a porch
somewhere and if there's baboons around,
they'll snatch him.
You need his head.
When I was in africa,
a hundred africa one time in my life and
the ph and our guide both said at our
church as a professional hunter,
right?
The structure is like there's a
professional hunter,
which is essentially your guide and then
there's trackers which are usually
native folks that that help tracking the
game spot in the animals,
things like that.
BuT our,
our ph,
he was like,
if you see a bad beer and shoot it,
it's like we have,
we have lots of irrigation here to
maintain this ranch and they rip it up
and they're basically terrorists around,
you know,
coming around our camp,
mess with our fires,
messing with our food.
If you see one sheet one,
and that was the instruction that I got
and I never,
never did.
But you know,
gIven that instruction from somebody
like that,
like,
hey,
this is a good thing for our landscape.
Go and do it now.
That's very far removed from stacking
them up.
Yeah,
like stack very far in with a big smile
on your face.
Hold on.
A bow
isn't.
It?
Doesn't make denise shoot a baby that
has some babies.
It's like a whole family.
How you can.
They don't stay in one place either.
You guys,
you and I said like,
listen joe,
here's my plan.
What I'm going to do is go to africa and
hunt and then,
you know,
like I'm going
to shoot some baboons.
I mean,
it's a good thing for this.
I'd be like,
don't tell anybody.
Yeah.
You'd be like,
don't,
don't take.
Certainly don't take a photo of you
posing with an entire family of the
deceased primate.
I had a friend who was in africa and he
got attacked by a ba boom,
boom,
ba boom,
steals food.
I forgot what the context of it was was
uh,
quite a few years ago.
But he said it was spooky.
He said they don't seem like a,
a monkey and they don't seem like they
seem like a dog monkey.
Electric wild.
You ever see when they open their mouth?
Yes.
It's like a dog mouth monkey.
It's like a dog fucked a monkey.
Like if you really like show a baboons,
baboons with his mouth open.
Never thought of it that way,
but I'll give it to you.
But they have a long stretched out
mouth,
like a wolf or something.
It's not like a werewolf.
Yeah.
It's not like a regular person.
The real weird man,
they,
they have all these characteristics that
are of primates,
but then they have this extra weirdness
to them and this wildness tune to it
doesn't have come down to like the core
of days.
Oh my god.
I mean,
come on,
look at that.
That's like a werewolf.
Yeah,
that is a werewolf that's like part.
Look at that.
Face that lion roll back.
But look at the,
even the shape of the jaw.
It's very dog.
Like it's very elongated and,
and dog like they're very.
It's a very strange animal.
Look at that face man.
And that is a crazy beast.
And my friend said,
I forget the story was quite a long time
ago,
but I stole some food and snarled at him
and snatch something from.
But he said it was very scary.
He said,
and you know,
it wasn't even that big with like 60,
70 pounds or something like that.
And he said,
but it's pending.
They'll fuck you up.
They'd say,
well,
you know,
it's different if you live in around
them.
It's Just these things are different.
Like we were talking about around the
old media to incorporate officers the
other day around how do you,
how do we as hunters who are around
these animals all the time and shit,
how do we.
Then something happens.
Somebody gets mad about this guy killing
all these,
these baboons.
What do we say when there's a hunting
scandal?
You why said,
oF course I let it go.
Well,
most people don't even know about it.
Yeah,
it is world,
but that one was on like nbc,
cnn,
this one,
this one was pretty big and there's.
There's invariably these things happen
where,
how come that didn't go as big as cecil
stop and think about that because to me
it's more,
it's more kind of fucked up.
It's more egregious than the cecil thing
was an it's a normal thing,
but I think I just think we're
desensitized to it.
Cecil came in at a time where there was
more sensitivity to it and it just hit a
new cycle like trump.
The trump news cycle probably dominates
any other thing that happens in the
news.
Well,
the reason why I say that cecil's
normal,
I don't think that it's good.
I don't think you should just go over
there and shoot lines,
but people been doing it forever.
Like if you asked me how many people go
over there to hunt baboons and be like,
do they really?
Is that like a normal thing?
Like does.
It doesn't seem normal.
Right?
Like even though I don't,
I mean I've had this conversation many
times on this podcast,
I don't think you should shoot things
that you don't eat unless there's a need
in terms of like some sort of an
imbalance,
like just as a joke.
Imagine if eagles were like rats.
They were everywhere.
There's a reason why you could just kill
rats because you have to,
okay,
this is what overpopulation looks like.
You,
you put a trap in your fucking garage
and you smash the head of this living
creature and you're happy.
Almost all things are categorized as
road until you do that too.
Well,
not true.
Really.
Right?
Like squirrels are cute.
They're adorable,
but they just don't get in your house.
But if they were getting,
there is half a dozen squirrels in your
garage and you could set traps and get
them out of there.
You would.
But it's a different thing.
Like you would feel bad if you stomped
one.
Probably I wouldn't.
You'd stomp a rat like people still.
You've saw a rat in your kid's room.
You'd fucking stump that thing to death
twice,
right?
If you saw a squirrel and your kids are
a blanket over it,
those types of value.
Why don't we apply those value systems
to animals like that?
What?
Because they're overpopulated and
because traditionally there have been
carriers have plague.
Will the real,
the real story about the black plague.
It's not just that the rats were
carrying,
but in fact that the ticks and the was
it ticks or fleas that were on the rats
were carrying the black plague.
If I want to say it's fleas,
could be.
And that this was how the bubonic plague
got spread.
It got spread actually,
in fact,
through the ticks that were carried by
the rats.
That what it is.
Fleas.
I'm.
Thank you jane with google search.
The,
uh,
the difference is that squirrels are not
overpopulated and that raptors are
killing them off,
like left and right.
It's a primary source of food for a lot
of these flying raptors,
eagles and hawks and stuff like that.
I'm sure a lot of other things eat them
too,
but there's enough balance out there.
But rats,
rats lock into us.
I mean,
they lived without us for a long time,
but once they found us,
they were like,
oh,
look at this shit.
These dumb mother fuckers have holes in
their ground.
You can live under their houses.
He just,
they put garbage out every day.
Just go jack.
They're garbage.
You got plenty of food.
This is,
will he treat all types of animals very
differently,
right?
And we apply our own specific feelings
about these animals to them.
Like the bear with the name doesn't know
that it has a name.
The wolf or the name doesn't know it has
a name.
It's not aware that we've applied this
special meaning to it.
It doesn't know that it's still our,
our application of our feelings and our
engendering this.
That doesn't change the nature of the
wolf or the bear.
It will rip your face off.
It will kill as many elk as it can.
Well,
there's a real problem in depicting
them,
the anthropomorphization of animals to
picks them as your friends and that's a
hard thing to shake.
There's not that they're bad and this is
where the real problem with someone
going around shooting baboons and posing
like you did.
A great thing is it's not that these
animals are bad.
They should be respected and understood
and appreciate.
Now,
if you are a part of a baboons cleanup
crew,
like if you're winning.
I was listening to rainelle is podcast
today and they were talking about
kangaroos in Australia and that there
was a guy on the show that had killed
somewhere near was like 7,000,
many thousands,
thousands like his dad's.
There was a.
What was it like?
There was a flood.
I'll probably mess this up.
There is some sort of weather event that
pushed all these kangaroos onto to his
dad's ranch and his dad was going out
every day and just whacking at nauseum
thousands of rows and that they have to
do this because they don't have any
natural predators and they.
They'll just devastate landscapes and
we've played videos.
Cvfi one real quick.
We'll play.
We'll get kicked off of youtube probably
right.
There's a video of like a swarm of
kangaroos in Australia.
Did I have?
No,
I had no idea.
We were reading about it,
about the overpopulation.
I had no idea.
It's just like hundred pound locust.
Yeah,
that's what I was reaDing.
I can't remember the guy's name,
but I was reading this paper just so I
can see.
It was reading.
Don't put it up on the youtube.
I don't want the kids to get out of.
There it is.
this is nothing.
This ain't.
This ain't shit in comparison.
This is pretty great.
Yeah.
These are all boobs.
This is pretty crazy,
but we were watching one when there was
a swarm running across a field.
Like,
look at that bro.
That's rats.
Come on,
man,
if you saw that many rats in a field,
you would go,
I am going to go get my gun and I'm
going to kill these fucking rats.
Right?
YOu wouldn't tolerate that,
but these are cute.
Is it like the endangered species act
coming into play here and in a weird way
because these are caring for animals
dictated by the number of the animal
that there is.
It isn't an.
It is.
See,
it's not for us.
right?
We're over here in the valley of
southern California and right brains.
Have a good old time.
Me buddy.
Ben o'brian,
young jamie have wonderful.
It's air conditioned with fantastic
fairness.
We live a good life here.
If you're in Australia,
you're killing those.
Fuck.
Oh,
let me tell you.
When I went,
remy warren,
our mutual friend first took me to New
Zealand.
He took me to a sheep station,
a giant that's basicallY a ranch,
big sheep ranch.
We hunted fallow deer,
the deer everywhere.
On the way out.
We met a guy,
we call him the rabbit man or like he.
He looked like a superhero.
He was riding on like a just a two
stroke bike with like a rabbit hide
covers for the handles.
He had a helmet on.
he was like a superhero,
like a leather jacket and was like a 22
and he was riding around.
His job was to ride around and shoot
rabbits all night long every day,
seven days a week.
He had killed millions of rabbits,
millions,
millions and he.
He would log every night,
come back and log the number of rabbIts
he killed.
They weren't eating these rabbits.
It was population control.
These robots were or digging under these
rabbits were destroying the landscape.
They couldn't run sheep.
That the land was invaluable because
these rabbits where it's almost like
turn of the century America.
We had some of the same situations,
but we met this guy who's job it was to
with impunity.
Kills many rabbits as he possibly could.
A rabbit's invasive species down there.
They might be.
Yeah,
we'll find out because this was New
Zealand and most like there's
everything.
Almost everything is non native and this
is a crazy spot.
Yeah.
That's one of my favorite spots.
I can be on the board for tourism for
New Zealand.
Really?
You're allowing the rabbits were
introduced to Australia and 18th
hundred.
Okay.
But what about New Zealand?
Jamie?
Not paying attention right next to right
next to.
I can't swim bro.
Rapid on swim,
but I bet it's the same thing.
Whereas the same thing.
I'm sure we never,
we never did get so deep into an
invasive species and number introduced
rabbit.
European rabbit.
Yeah.
They,
I think everything in in New Zealand was
introduced most most.
Sorry.
New zealanD really needs to kill these
adorable rabbits.
yeah.
They have to.
By the way.
You can eat them.
They're fucking dogs.
Rabbits are delicious.
Yeah.
I mean it's.
But at the problem as my daughter has a
fucking pet rabbit.
Okay.
And uh,
we put it in this little cute cage and
when it wants to come out and be held
and puts his little paws on tissue,
did it makes noise.
You opened the cage up,
take the rabbit out,
you know.
But it was delicious.
It can't go out and.
Fuck,
I love hunting rabbits,
man.
Malicious.
But I was reading this,
this,
uh,
environmental.
It was like a theorist.
This guy was talking about the types of
hunting and I was reading this.
I'm like,
this is not,
this might be a smart guy,
but he don't have it.
He was talking about three types of
hunting.
Therapeutic.
What is that?
James was in That period with the
rabbits.
It said stoats.
Stoked.
I've never heard of it.
It's keating.
It's eating a nested bird.
Probably another cute.
But except for one of the things that
also I learned about from the mediator
podcast is a,
how many squirrels kill birds?
Oh yeah.
They kill and eat birds.
I think that's a big part of the
decimation of the population of certain
bird species is squirrel.
I'm interested in this.
Literally eats fucking mice.
He's a murderer.
That's crazy.
That little thing.
Eat a mouse.
that's about what's a rat?
it's a rat.
That's like his size.
Is this something that's on New Zealand?
I think.
I believe so.
I've done murder.
Only thing I've run into that was native
to New Zealand was a kia.
It was like a parrot that flies around.
Was the thylacine native to New Zealand
or Australia?
That's Australia,
right?
That's the tasmanian tiger.
Or also known as your total weasel?
He's nine ounces.
Just America.
North America is just how little fuckers
out here and stuff.
Oh,
okay.
got over here.
Distinguished by.
Oh,
he's a weasel.
It looks like a larger size and longer
tail with a prominent black tip.
It's kind of weasel was terrific.
Level of carnivorous.
Isn't it funny that weasels are thought
to be like a little bitches?
You little weasel.
We're bad ass.
This weasel.
There he goes.
Look at him.
Yeah.
And weasels will fuck up a cobra.
How about that?
Look at him.
What does he do in the hills and rabbit?
That's how he's killing.
Look at it.
Kills rabbit 10 times its size.
Its christ.
2 million views.
There it is.
Oh there it is.
Look how small he is and he's chasing a
rabbit.
That's insane.
What a little ruthless motherfucker
probably on like don't show it,
but it was very cute.
So should we do the play by play on like
stout?
Oh,
life stout kills rabbit 10 times a stoat
or I don't know.
It was.
It stowed her style.
I don't know.
I'd rather this of my time outside
fucker.
Look at him.
Go.
He really is 10 times the size.
He's.
He's kind of adorable though.
The way they doing it.
What's he going to do?
He's going to go for the hindquarters,
like a wolf.
The other rabbit to stop him because
like captain,
save a hoe over there.
I mean this one.
Oh.
Oh,
that's some pass by.
Was going low.
How about the other rabbit just sits
there was friends.
Gets just dozens of rabbits that aren't
like,
let's gang up and get this dope man.
How crazy Is he?
Doesn't try the really close to him.
Now.
He goes,
where's he going?
Is he going like,
so he's Probably going to hit those.
He's going to hit those hind quarters.
You're going to get some shock and some
blood loss.
Now he's gone.
He's gone again.
He's going to pull them down with the
blood loss and you get,
you know,
he's going,
oh joe rogan.
He's going up.
Oh god.
Oh my god.
Back look at the other rabbits.
What's going on?
It was like,
this doesn't seem right.
The other rabbits.
It just going to look away you pussy.
We're not friends that are going to help
your friend.
what a little monster.
Oh,
that is so crazy.
He's deep on it.
That is so he's got his teeth for those.
I don't know who's watching,
but he's got his teeth like behind the
ears of this random.
He's killing it by biting the back of
his neck and he literally is 10 times
smaller than that.
Is it dead right there or the other?
I was like,
thank you bbc fucking dorks help your
friend.
that's why you're going to go extinct.
You fucking bastard.
How about you bitch?
Turning them a bite him in the neck.
It really is that they're stout.
You think s t o a t e s it seems like it
would be stout,
you know,
but uh,
you would be stout and stout.
A stalled backwards stout.
Never seen one of those before.
MY time outside.
Never heard of.
Never heard.
No.
I didn't even know it wAs a thing too
though.
They're savage,
next thing you know they're going to be,
they're going to be like nipping at your
calf trying to take you down.
That should be the american animal,
not an eagle weasels in Ireland and here
I go.
Everywhere else they're called short
tailed weasels kind of weasel
ways.
Those are vicious little motherfuckers.
That's what I'm saying.
Like why are weasels like the wheat?
So think about like pauly shore.
When he would do the weasel,
you thought of him.
We'd sell in.
He didn't think of him as being a
ruthless killer or something 10 times.
And those are cute.
Like if pauly shore was taken down,
giant bitches,
huge,
25 feet tall.
Women.
I just smashing them,
you know,
like that would be what
little animal.
But that even the way that that little
weasel was chasing the rabbit was kind
of cute.
like he Was just bounding along,
adore in adorable.
It was aDorable.
So he would run by.
He was so mean.
He would run by the other rabbits like
he had determined about this rabbit.
This brings up like we were on my
podcast.
We had a guy on there named brandy
newburgh.
You know about that,
randy?
Yeah.
Randy Is awesome.
Yeah,
that's great.
Lives in bozeman and he's great and we
were talking.
We did a deal about ethics and a lot of
folks wrote in and they said,
I'd be interested to hear what you think
about this.
If if an animal is wounded and you're
say you're up in a tree stand or you're
hunting,
you know,
spot and stalk,
or you're in the case of randy hunting
over a waterhole.
If you're doing that in,
in you're a hunter,
you hold a tag.
You can choose which animal you'd like
to kill,
right?
You have a buck or a doe,
male or female tag.
What you can choose which one he wants
to kill it.
If an animal comes by you that has been
wounded,
clearly been wounded,
clearly struggling,
you know,
in the case of a rainy newburgh,
he was sitting on a waterhole and I
believe he was in Arizona with a trophy
tag,
which means there was a lot of big meal
too.
You're walking around and a lot of big
antelope walking around there in that
situation.
Pronghorn.
Let's explain to people that are
listening that don't know what we're
talking about.
When he says a trophy tag.
What he means is there's some units that
are designated as trophy areas.
It doesn't meAn you don't eat them.
the animal.
What it does mean is that it's very
difficult to get into this area.
Yes.
To have a certain amount of points which
means you are putting in to the pool of
money.
That is a for conservation for habitat
protection.
All you're puttIng in every year to try
to get a tag and you could only get a
tag and a lot of these places once in a
lifetime for some places,
10 years on tags that are once every 15
years.
I mean it's very complicated point
system,
but yeah.
What,
what's.
explain why they do that,
they do that to preserve the population
of big mature animals so that this.
You can't just let anybody go in.
Like there's some places that are called
over the counter,
over the counter unit is is they know
that there's a large healthy population
of animals and they either the wildlife
biologists in the state representative,
they choose to just let anybody go in
and when they think the animals are
diminishing too much,
then they'll put a cap on it.
But for now it's an over the counter
unit.
Yes.
And then they have places that are very
difficult to draw units.
Yeah.
And those difficult to
draw units is one of the places where
randy newburgh was because he was
looking for a big old mature animal that
it spreads genetic and it's tough.
Like the term turf has been so
weaponized.
It's tough.
It's my fault for using like when you
use.
I use it not in the term that most
peopLe think of it.
I think of trophies,
a lot of different things.
I'm a mature animal.
That's again,
once in a lifetime.
It takes many,
many years to draw.
I think you should just call it a
limited,
limited jarl unit draw.
You know,
hard to get every once in a lifetime
hunt where you're never going to hunt
there again and you're looking for the
most unique animal that you can find,
the most mature animal that you can
find,
but along the way,
yeah,
like in this case,
ethically,
he runs into a limping,
antelope pronghorn it comes into a
waterhole on is limping to the point
where he thinks,
oh,
I'm,
and this happens to a lot of hunters.
He's like,
oh,
I have this tag.
I've waited a long time to get it.
It's a very unique tag,
of course,
is the way you explained it and would I
know I can eat this animal just the same
as I would any other one,
but to to to exercise some mercy around
this antelope that's clearly suffering,
clearly injured.
Who knows how iT got injured to limping
up to a water hole.
He's.
He's having this ethical.
I'm pondering in his head like,
should I dispatch this thing and it's
suffering.
Fill my tag this way because with a,
with a tag and that tag,
you can then choose to do anything you
want with it in legal bounds.
You wish you didn't wound this animal so
you could let that animal pass and
choose a a larger,
more mature and more impressive than
them and you get to let nature take its
course,
whether a predation or not in the case
of this one,
but winter kill or something may take
that animal or you can
and it's a quote unquote suffering.
You doN't know.
We can't talk tO the animal and ask it
his opinion,
but you can end what looks like it's
suffering and fill your tag in that way.
That's not the way normal hans play out,
but a lot of hunters are put in that
situation.
Cool situation.
It's pretty rare,
but it can happen.
It can happen.
It never happened to me,
but what we did is your answer,
so the answer,
his answer was to shoot.
That was a shoot,
that analog.
I agree with that.
You know why?
Because also here's another possibility.
No,
antelopes come by.
Yeah,
so if no nos come by,
just by fate,
you don't get an animal,
so you spend seven days out there in the
wilderness and you come home empty
handed,
you don't get to eat an antelope or
you're presented with this opportunity
to be merciful,
to take this animal out that's injured
and you get to keep an antelope and
although it's not the antelope that you
dreamed of,
it's something that would still healthy
meal.
You get to feel good.
The fact that you really did,
you put an animal out of its misery and
and we all like mercy is a virtue.
Yeah,
for sure.
We all would like to be like,
and I,
and I said this in in randy kind of,
we talked through it,
but I said that,
that this is a unique situation to a
hunter.
If you're a hiker and you come across an
animal wounded in this way or injured in
this way,
there's very little you can do.
Yeah,
but this is unique
to the hunter's responsibility to look
at this animal and make this decision.
Here's another argument.
another argument is you really should do
nothing because those are the animals
that are designated to be taken out by
the predators and you want to keep the
predator population.
That was more my answer.
Randy's answer.
Like we,
we went back and forth course and um,
I see both sides.
I see both sides too.
And I think this,
that's one of those situations where as
a hunter there was a,
you know,
I'll go back,
there's another Podcast I did with a guy
named do sean's Montana and he,
uh,
his,
his real name,
he's fantastic.
John's Montana,
who?
Shawn smith.
Dan is from checklists of akio.
He's an outdoor photographer and he's,
he's a dope individual at a wonderful
human that'd be with that name.
He's,
he lives up to that.
And tHe important thing we'd like sit by
his fire,
like,
let me say the [inaudible] fire.
And because we were handmade boots,
of course he does show the fuck out of
here.
What do you think he's aware?
And he would make his own moccasins and
most interesting man in the world.
He's verY much this.
He likes.
So I did a podcast with him,
we sat by his fire and we drank plum
brandy that he makes himself.
Of course it does.
Really.
He makes his own honey.
He has icelandic sheep that he shares
and he eats.
He does a sada.
He kills a lamb everywhere and feeds
everyone.
Assad.
Wonderful human being.
He grew up in checklists of akio and
part of his describing his,
his growing up is like in,
there's a term,
and I'll,
I'll butcher the pronunciation of it,
but mikayla,
vic is the term that he used to describe
a hunter as like hunter or the one who
thinks and the way he described the
culture,
the cultural significance of 100 and
his,
you know,
um,
when he was growing up in the late
eighties and,
and checklist vacuum was that the hunter
had to be,
was the,
was the judge and jury.
So there was like a reverenCe around
hunting or reverence around a hunter
because hunter got the privilege in,
in his culture to be the judge and jury
for what animal it gets taken out of the
herd.
Like making that very serious decision
to say,
this animal is wounded,
this animal is too old,
this animal is young enough.
Right?
You've talked about a lot on this
podcast with some other smart hunters
that I think what hunting needs to
become now that it isn't,
is this exalted status in our society
where we're at,
we're giving somebody with a hunting tag
or a hunting license.
You're giving somebody the opportunity
to make a decision about somethings
life.
Well,
you say exalted status.
THe problem is you don't have to earn
that status,
right?
You could just go out and do it,
and one of the things that I've found
out about hunting that is a.
I don't know if it's necessarily
surprising,
but it's.
It's very difficult to express without
personal experience,
is that it?
The consequences are.
it's so different than what you would
think.
It's very difficult to do.
It's very physically
exhausting.
The coNsequences of your actions are so
grave in the rewards are so much
different than any other way of
acquiring food.
Even fIshing,
which I love.
I love fishing.
I love fish.
I like to eat them.
They're delicious.
They are delicious.
I'd catch them.
They're fun.
I like catching fish.
It's not the same.
There is something that we in and I
don't think this is a learned thing.
I think there is a.
There's a connection to difficult to
acquire mammals that goes deep in our
dna and I think this is the reason whY
we.
I think one of the reasons why we enjoy
fishing is because those reward systems
were put in place by people that
survived by eating fish,
by all those generations of people that
did catch fish and that was how they ate
that day.
That excitement lives inside of you and
you sparked that up.
When you get a big steel head on,
he hear that real go because you're
being informed,
being informed by people that didn't
have a choice man.
Like these are people that had to have
that fish to live.
Exactly.
So even though it's recreation to you,
it's a thrilling recreation,
but then the consequences aren't as
grave.
There's something about a wounded deer
or wounded elk that is so horrific and
immersive,
merciful killing that is so.
It's so such a relief.
It's,
there's something powerful about it.
Like I told you,
I shot that elk,
that it's out there that walked four
yards and I'm not exaggerating for yards
and fell over.
It was dead like that.
And the guYs who were there,
they said it was quicker than any rifle
shot they'd ever seen an elk die.
So they,
they usually stand up longer from that.
That's what everybody wants.
That horses,
it wants it.
They want a course they do,
but if I catch a fish and uh,
he's a,
I pull them out of the water and throw
them on the ice and he's flopping around
for a few hours.
I'm just happy I got him.
Yeah,
it's different.
Well,
they'd like,
you've had michael pollen on the show
before he wrote that omnivore's dilemma.
And in it he just said basically,
and I'm paraphrasing,
but he said it hunting is so different
from the inside than it is from the
outside.
Yes.
So easy to view hunting in the lens of
like there's a dude sitting behind a
deer smiling and grabbing its antlers.
There's also the problem that
malnutrition.
This country is almost nonexistent.
Fat people are poor people in this
country,
which is fucked.
Like poor people are fat.
Yeah.
Which is one of the weirder things about
our society.
This has never heard.
This has never happened in the history
of human beings that the poor people
with the big fat ones,
they got Cell phones.
I mean,
there's a lot of rich people that are
fat too.
Don't get me wrong,
but there's people who don't have a
problem being fat.
Sure.
Right,
and this doesn't mean that does not a
lot of malnutrition there.
most certainly is,
but it's nutrition.
It's not.
There's not a lack of calories.
Lack of calories was a massive problem
throughout most of human history.
The lack lack of food,
so it's the.
The access to food Is so normal to us.
It's so easy,
but the unfettered access to food is
what's really normal now.
That's what's changed with
industrialization and coming on fast,
fast food is processed,
food is fucked.
Yeah.
He had.
If you go back to when people,
when hunting was more normal in the 19
twenties or the 19 thirties are really
normal.
There was also no fast food.
Yeah.
So when you would get a roast,
even if you went into a butcher and you
got a roast and you brought it home and
you were making roast beef and you're
cooking it,
or your uncle shot a deer,
sat milk was delivered to your door.
Yeah.
not my dad,
you know.
So there's a lot of different.
It was wrong.
Yeah.
So there's a lot of different.
Yeah,
like the removal from
the actual process that hunters go
through,
but actually it might not have been raw.
Right.
When did they start pasteurizing and
modernization?
The jamie thing that was,
um,
louis pester best.
That is who it was a realization,
right.
That's,
that's what it came from.
Past Louis pasteurized milk.
Um,
when did they start implementing that?
Like when you would get the milk on your
door and those glass jars.
Didn't that milk go bad quick though?
But that's,
you know,
my grandparents,
that's what they would describe the
milkman.
18 eighties.
So when it started,
that's when it started.
I wonder when it was common.
I wonder if
when you think about like market
hunting,
we always talk about an hunting,
like the turn of the century being this
huge moment in hunting,
conservation market hunting really
became a thing when when it accelerated,
when refrigeration became a reality,
right and accelerated when railroads
could take meat from the great american
west back to the cities in the east
coast and so those things like excel or
that technology and those things,
accelerated market hunting and the
depredation of things like the white
tail deer and and and the buffalo as we
all same.
I'm just trying to flavor this and the
context of most people that hear these
conversations don't really know what
we're talking about.
Yeah,
so you.
You're obviously well versed in this,
but for a lot of folks,
they don't understand that.
What haPpened was after the civil war in
particular,
there's a lot of soldiers,
they weren't fighting anymore in the war
and they got jobs as hunters and they
would just go out with no rules and
shoot as many animals as they wanted
and we.
The term we call that as market hunting
and their market hunting means that
they're out hunting for marketing the
meat or marketing,
the hides of marketing parts of the
animal.
To them it's just the tongue.
Which buffaloes for just the tongue.
Yep.
So at that time,
and are at the turn of the century,
right?
18,
eighties,
turn of the century.
We had mass mass killings of people just
think of buffalo really?
But white tail deer,
mallard duck,
wild turkeys,
elk,
black bear,
black bear ever get that?
Jesus christ.
Yes.
This is a.
We're looking at
a photograph of like so many fucking
animals just hanging from these docks
there.
And mostly it looks like all ducks.
I don't see anything,
but there's nothing.
What are those?
A whole.
What are those easter eggs like bears.
Those are all ducks.
Yeah.
Um,
so there's the market hunting deer,
but they decimated massive quantities of
these wild game and they were like the
hair.
There's more whites healthier today.
Then when christopher columbus landed on
this continent at the time,
at the turn of the century,
when at the height of the market on
crisis in this country,
there were,
there were enough,
there were enough white tail deer that
they probably would have been on the
endangered species list or been close
and so the model of conservation that we
then enacted.
I don't want to say like,
I don't want to overexerts approval.
I've never heard of it,
but if you look at the,
if you look up jamie,
the north american model of wildlife
conservation,
there was,
there was a ton of key figures in taking
what America had at that point,
which was basically the wild west where
animals are dying at mass and with,
with railroads and refrigeration.
Like we said,
tHey're then feeding and clothing at
that time.
The masses in the urban settings,
you know,
in New York and different places.
But as,
as the centuries turned over.
And did you get into the teens and
twenties guys like teddy roosevelt give
her pinochet there.
You know john [inaudible].
There was a bunch of figures who
essentially kicked off what is american
conservation movement,
the movement to conserve not only the
wildlife populations,
but wildlands in wild waters and
significant places in this country that
we needed to protect because around the
turn of the century we did not have that
feeling of value as a society.
There wasn't a like,
we have to go value that thing we've
never seen because you could never see
it.
Right?
And so we,
they were,
they went,
they set about building a value
structure for not only wildlife but wild
places.
And they also said about a,
uh,
a way that the user would pay for this
conservation and this,
these are the constructs of what we now
know to be the north american model of
wildlife conservation,
which,
I mean,
this is,
if you look at it today,
it's like one of the most successful and
like the seminal systems of conservation
in the world in the world.
It wasn't reallY codified until the
eighties until guys like larry is dr
boulerice geist and shane mahoney and
folks wrote it down and said,
this is what it is.
But pull it,
if you could pull up the tenants of the
north american model because I can list
them off,
but north american model of wildlife
conservation,
wildlife as public trust resources,
elimination of markets for game,
like that's what people say,
hey,
where can I buy some elk?
You can
can't.
You can buy from zealand.
Wildlife.
Wildlife is a public trust that just
basically means the states hold the
wildlife and trust for the public.
these animals belong to us.
STate holds them in trust and manage
them in interest for us.
Now,
for people that have a problem,
that as an idea that we would own a
living thing.
The only reason for that is to protect
those living things.
I understand on semantics that you would
have issue with either humans shouldn't
in life,
man,
we don't and maybe own is the wrong word
to use.
Maybe owned is the wrong word to use,
but it's like manage and cohabitate
with.
Maybe that's the better way to say this
by being by looks.
Whether we protect them or whether we
decimate them.
Right?
We are the stewards of the land,
but we are.
We are the ones,
the monkeYs with the guns.
That's just if we have the ability to
say,
here's this number of animals,
here's this number of land,
here's,
here's how we encourage upon that land.
Let's study that.
Make sure that's all good.
Yes,
and then let's manage It as actively
managed as hunters and anglers to make
sure the carrying capacity of this land
meets the wildlife populations.
Everything is working in order to.
It's the sustainable use of natural
resource.
That's what hunting is.
If anybody asks you like,
hey,
hey dude,
what's hunting?
You say hunting in the north american
model is the sustainable use of natural
resource.
Yes.
To eat,
to eat elimination,
have markets for game.
We covered,
covered none of these animals that we're
talking about,
whether you're eating black bear or
whether eating deer,
you cannot buy that stuff.
If you buy it,
you're going to get raised.
Farm,
raised meat and most of it is from New
Zealand.
Yep.
Allocation of wildlife by law,
right?
There's laws,
There is a law to say how many animals
you can kill if you just like that fell
in Missouri.
That's gotta.
Watch bambi if you kill more than we're
supposed to kill your approach now
you've broken the law
and the law is dictated and most really
good states like Montana by wildlife
biologists,
conservationists and people that
understand the population and what's a
healthy population for the area.
Yep.
And how to maintain a correct balance.
And there's a real science to that
folks.
You know,
the,
the science of when you talked to
wildlife biologists about this,
this,
I mean,
we had a great podcast with doug during
brian.
Brian's last name.
Love doug.
Darren was a fucking.
Can't remember my shitty brain.
Um,
but we,
we were talking about cwd,
chronic wasting disease,
the spread of it amongst wild animals.
And then just richard's Brian Richards.
Shout out to Brian Richards and me pal,
doug,
darren.
But doug,
great dogs the best.
Keep fighting that fight over there.
So what we talked about was the actual
science behind this one particular
issue,
but you grow to appreciate when you hear
someone like him talk the grow to
appreciate the complex nature of
wildlife biology and maintaining the
populations of animals,
keeping keeping them healthy and making
sure that these habitats are preserved.
This is very complicated.
Oh,
it's.
It's impossible to really understand the
scope of these to take Wyoming or
Montana.
We,
we Tend to cordon off things we really
care about like,
oh,
grizzly bears in the greater yellowstone
ecosystem.
We really care about that.
That's the thing to talk about,
but really what we should talk about is
really what most wildlife managers are
looking at is just like biodiversity and
health of all wildlife populations and
it predator prey,
predator prey,
balance.
Like these are things that we've,
that we've set about in this model of
conservation to say like we're not just
by license,
by license.
We are using science and biology to
dictate the way in which hunting is used
to benefit these populations back.
OH,
it's gone,
jamie.
Googling porn.
A wildlife can only be killed for a
legitimate purpose.
That kind of says it all right.
It does,
but that.
What does that mean is where it gets
weird when people like,
um,
here's one goes to that.
People get really crazy.
They'll get really crazy when you kill
predators.
Even if you can eat them.
Like I was looking at Adam Green trees
page and braintree shot a cougar.
Did he send you that?
He has not.
He's going to be here and we're gonna
cook it together.
Whoa.
Going to cook some mountain lion
I hear till it's delicious.
I've never had.
You have.
I haven't had it like that.
I've shot.
But somebody else prepared.
Would you say you hear tell,
but you have had.
I have had it and it is delicious.
Are you being coy?
Being coy at all?
I hear.
I like to sound folksy.
So people are saying what I'm saying,
but no,
it's,
it's like lean and delicate and it gets
like pork almost.
It's really good.
And then people will go crazy.
Like why are you killing that?
Do you understand how fucked it is that
you have zero problem with someone
killing a deer,
but you have a problem,
someone killing a mountain lion and this
is a real problem with someone killing
something that will fucking kill you if
it catches you alone in the forest.
Yeah,
fucking for sure.
Kill your dog for sure.
Kill your kids.
Definitely killed those cute little deer
and kill a shitload of them like one
every couple of days for its entire life
and wherever they're experts at it and
for whatever reason we get it in our
head that if,
and I think this comes from this whole
idea of trophy hunting,
that if you kill something like that,
you're only killing that thing because
you have a little dick and it doesn't
work.
You going to be a big man,
so you killed this thing that's better
than you in this beautiful animal.
The definition of a surface level
examination.
It is,
but it isn't because this is the.
This is the narrative that's been pushed
through all the channels.
They don't,
unless they go out and research this
stuff objective in depth.
And why would you they.
Let's be,
let's be devil's advocate.
Why would you,
if you're an accountant,
what do I want to look into?
The subtleties of predator hunting for
us to keep that up,
please.
Why?
Why do I want it?
Why do I give a fuck about that?
Like why don't we get some assholes
wants to shoot mountain lions,
but crazy.
Always good to use dogs.
Oh wow.
That's so unfair.
We talk for.
Can we talk for a minute about baiting
bears?
Yes.
With it's,
can we,
we want to keep legitimate purpose.
Let's keep legitimate purpose.
Right?
But I read if you want to keep that down
for the light,
is that what it is?
So just paid it back up when we need it.
We'll get to it.
Um,
there's,
I,
I read this,
I've read stories and you and I baited
it.
WenT hunting for bears baited before.
And so I've heard a lot of in hunting,
they have the term fair chase,
which means a legitimate reason for the
ability for the to escape.
You're hunting the animal,
in all fairness,
in the pursuit,
um,
people beat,
beat up on bated bear hunting a lot,
probably because bears are involved,
probably because it seems unfair to sit
in a chair and put out some donuts or
put out some,
uh,
dead beaver put out whatever attracts a
bear to put a smell out into the forest.
The bear smells it,
it comes to eat and you're there to kill
it.
That seems like what lazy seems like.
That seems a lot of cheating.
Cheating.
So people would say that's not fair.
Chase,
ethical.
Right?
And,
and in some ways I agree with that in
comparison to other ways of hunting,
right?
but at the same time I can say,
I can tell you this,
there's no more ethical if the idea is
to kill the animal,
killed the right animal,
especially in,
in bear hunting,
you're trying to kill a specific bore.
A male bear that is pass holder past
breeding.
Anybody who's bear hunting will tell you
one of the hardest things to judge on,
it's on while it's living is a bear.
Whether it's a male or a female,
how big it is,
how old it is.
They are hard to judge because they're
black.
They they slide through the forest that
I'll look that they don't stay.
There's no markers.
Like if the bear is standing next to a
volkswagen bug.
Yeah.
You go,
oh,
okay.
I know how big a bug is.
That's right now.
How big the bears.
That's right.
The bear is nexus and treat.
It's 100 yards away.
You really can't tell.
It's hard.
So spotting and stalking.
Well we call spotting and stalking
wishes like walking around,
trying to find a better.
Looking at it far away and getting close
enough to kill it.
Whether it's with a rifle or bow.
There's a lot of problems with what
seems to be a fair way to it to achieve
the pursuit of that animal.
There's a ton of problems around that
because they're hard to judge.
You could come up on a sow,
a female bear that has cubs in a bush
and he not see the cubs,
not know that it's a sow.
You're far away with a rifle.
You crack,
you kill it.
To culture and out of the bush,
that is not what you were trying to do.
You made a mistake there.
In the scenario where you are at,
a bait site is animal comes in,
it's walking around very close to where
you are.
You get to judge it,
you get to look between its legs,
see if it has a dick or not,
and then just determined it's the animal
you want to dispatch and dispatch it
ethically because it's closer to you.
It's 20 yards,
it's stabilized.
A lot of times it doesn't know,
hopefully doesn't know you're there
rather than doing it from further away
or having to stock close to it.
So I say all this to say like this is
complex.
What you think might be fair chase,
what you think you might want to apply
your own levels of fairness to doesn't
always equal the reality of pursuing
that animal.
If the end game is to dispatch it fairly
and kill it fairly,
bears are a very unique animal in that
there's so much more criticism because
of teddy bears and yogi and fucking coca
cola commercials.
We have this idea of what a bear is.
Yes,
and it's also the thing is,
and this is hard for people to accept
those old bores that were trying to kill
there.
If you kill them,
it's better for the whole population of
bears because they eat bears.
Now.
This is where it gets really fucked up.
And uh,
you know,
my friend jonathan who is a,
you met john and jen,
of course,
we were up there with them.
JonaThan,
their son,
saw one of the bears kill and start
consuming a cub female,
scared the bear off.
And then eight,
her own kid.
I've listened to
podcasts.
I,
a guy named cole kramer,
who I've hunted on kodiak island with.
He seen bear,
he seen male bears chase down,
sal's run them into a cave,
rip him and he's watched them rip cubs
and rip them in half and eat them and
spit them out like you know.
And once you've seen That you're,
you're,
you know,
no matter how many bear cartoons we
show,
no matter how many times a bear has
suspenders on,
in,
is talking to us.
It doesn't change no matter how many
times we name a bear,
it doesn't change the bareness of the
animal.
It doesn't change.
It's prime,
different animal.
It's a different kind of animal.
So there's nothing we can do to change.
bear being a bear.
I don't think there's any evidence that
they don't eat their own kids either.
I don't think there is.
Right?
I'm sure somebody,
you know,
somebody way more educated me can tell
you exactly what's happening there,
but we know you and I both know that
they're killing those two.
They're kiLling as many clubs as I can
to get this out,
to come back
heat.
They're doing that and they're also
doing it for food.
Food as well.
They eat them and they also try to bring
the saddleback and astro.
So your thing is,
you've talked about this before.
Hunters are in a specific,
you know,
are in a really interesting position to
have seen to see these things and be
intimate with these animals,
which is if you just explain what you
explained to most people,
they would just snap head back like
what?
They're cannibals,
100 percent of them are cannibals.
Yeah.
Even the ones that were suspended.
It is it.
It's this.
I think what nonhunters want from
hunters is,
is to one say,
listen,
this a complex thing that we're doing,
right.
We're going into a wild place and
removing from.
It's something we didn't put there.
Fuck that serIous.
But that's not.
We shouldn't be nonchalant about that.
we shouldn't celebrate it in ways that
make it seem irreverent like that.
That we should.
We should understand it's serious and
take that action.
Seriously.
We should be,
you know again that guy do sean and he
was explaining and checklists of ikea to
go hunting.
You had to go take a class and learn
flora and fauna and learn how many
pheasant eggs were in a,
in a nest.
And in real.
Yeah.
And then once you became a hunter in the
terms that they describe it,
then you had to like,
it was the amount of work you put into
the forest that denote and what you
could then hunt.
You know,
so if you went to cut down this many
trees,
you could go hunt a deer if you only did
one certain thing,
you could hunter rabbit,
like they had this.
Yeah,
he describes it as this like interaction
with.
So that was the model that was her model
of conservation was very much like
accountability and so I think what most
nonhunters want from hunters because for
me,
I don't think about anti hunters as much
as i think about somebody who just is
smart,
thoughtful,
he's never been.
You were this way at some point you're
like person who really thought hard
about what you were eating and wanted to
explore what is happening here.
Is there alternative ways?
So I think what non went from hunters is
for us to say,
listen,
we get it complex,
we get it's a serious thing and we're
doing our best to unpack the moral and
ethical entanglements in what we do.
Yeah.
And it's,
it's not easy.
I mean,
we flush pheasants when we could shoot
them on the ground and that's the way we
do what we call that fair chase,
but we don't like when an animal comes
close enough to us and eats the corn
that we can shoot it.
Like we don't like that either.
So these,
these things are entangled there.
It's hard to.
It's,
it's a hard activity.
Two to reckon with.
Well the baiting part of it is,
is it's,
it's absolutely not as good.
Yes.
I'm not saying I'm out there bait and
every animal,
but I'm saying I could just see as
somebody who likes the nuance of this
and likes to explore this and likes to
ask why.
Why,
why is it that that's the case?
Why is it,
do we look down on people that,
that bait animals and board use dogs.
Nobody use dogs to st.
Same reason.
They do it for the exact same reasons.
So they get a close up ethical shot on
the difficult to pursue an animal.
Yeah.
And it's,
it always goes back to like the reasons
we do what we do,
but.
But again,
I,
I would hope that everybody listening to
this,
lots of people do that don't hunt.
They would,
uh,
they would ask themselves like,
what do I,
what do I expect from hunters?
Like what is the thing that I expect you
to do to earn?
because I,
I very much feel is 100.
I need to earn the respect of the non
hundred.
Like I have a,
I have a duty to my hunting community to
actively earn the respect of every 900 I
run into.
I feel like I got to do it and maybe
I'm,
maybe I'm just making it harder for
myself.
But I,
I feel like there's,
it's an almost impossible task.
But I've done.
you've probably done it.
I've done it on a one to one level.
Yeah,
I definitely have flipped people
especially easy,
easier.
It's much easier when they eat meat.
We eat meat.
It makes sense.
Yes.
But then they'll still have a problem
with the bear thing.
And the bear thing is when you got to
sit them down with like,
I don't,
I don't prefer to hunt bears.
I don't in any way because I don't get
weirded out about tricking gnosis.
It's just the meat is not as good to me.
It's good.
It tastes great.
You have a nice roast or bear stir fry
or something.
It is delicious.
So it's not like you spit it out,
but it's not also comparative to elac.
It's like man,
okay.
Yeah.
You can't even have it medium rare,
which is the best way to eat meat.
That's right.
So it's not the same to me,
but if I lived like an alberta where
john and jen live,
I would realize that it's imperative you
have to do and if you do like detail and
if you do like to eat deer and if you do
like deep moose is really your
responsibility to hunt bear.
Yeah.
Because they kill 50 percent of all the
moose calves,
the calves and the deer fauns 50 percent
get killed by black bear.
Now here's the other thIng.
You could say,
well that's because nature has bounce
and the reason why they're there.
So those fucking Deer don't look at
those kangaroo in that park.
And that's true too.
That's true to the right and I think
it's our job to not have any sort of
bias when it comes to our examination of
this information,
whether it's flattering or not.
We have to be able to look at this
subjectively.
We ain't got to be pragmatic.
Yes,
have to,
and you have to be honest and I think
this is.
You'll have to address the complexity.
You have to realize that this is very
complex,
but guess what?
Fuck face.
If you wear a leather shoes,
you got clothes,
you got a leather interior in your car
eating cheeseburgers,
you should probably shut the fuck up.
we're human consumption engines.
We breathe in and breathe out.
We consume the world around us.
That's the way it works as you always
say life is life and that,
but the reality of the situation for me
is like I've tried to not stray away
from but try to add onto the pragmatic
arguments for hunting to try to examine
like the emotional issues we have around
caring for the single animal over caring
for the entire species of,
of that animal or in any case,
subspecies of that like that.
That to me,
somethiNg I've tried to add on,
like let's first start with praGmatic
arguments.
Like you eat meat,
you're fucking killing things.
Like why aren't you thinking this hard?
As I'm thinking about this and in a.
I really would love to build a bridge
with people to say I care.
Like if you're in a.
Let's say you're an anti hunter and you
love animal,
you're a vegan,
you a lot of conversation about b and
I'm a v,
I really care about animals are sentient
beings.
They all deserve life.
Put that person in front of me and then
I'll stand right beside them and be
like,
I fucking
agree with you.
I agree that all animals are sent to you
at beings.
I agree that they all deserve life and I
and then I go to preserve that life for
that animal.
that's what I go to do.
We start me in that anti hunter.
I'm a hunter.
Start at the same point and then over
the years board of sword that it's those
animals I do so that that eliminates you
from their side,
but that instantly,
yes,
because your diet,
but you're an animal consuming machine.
This person's the animal consumer
machine.
TheY're just not admitting it.
They just don't understand.
They just don't understand it mean
machine because they don't organically
garden.
Yes.
If they organically gardened and neat,
everythIng that they grow themselves,
even then it's hard to detach yourself
from your consumption of the world
because it's hard.
Like what's.
What's in your compost,
bro?
Yeah.
it,
it makes it easier for you.
Let's just leave the vegan out of the
conversation.
Say the non hunter is like,
I don't kill animals myself,
but I care about them.
I'm like,
I care about them and I kill him.
Were at the same,
like if you removed the second part of
the sentence,
the first part is I care about them,
right?
We both care about animals.
We're standing at one point and over
time,
whether it's mass media or just the way
hunting has been marketed in the poor pr
agent that we've had,
we've kind of walked away from each
other,
right?
We started with,
we both care about animals that we've
kind of walked away from each other and
over time we've been unwilling to turn
around and face each other and be like,
remember when we started out thinking we
all value these animals,
we value their lives,
we all care about them.
Hunting is just a version,
our version and it's worked.
given that model of conservation where
you're talking about,
it's worked for the white tail deer in
the mallard duck.
It's worked.
There's more than ever.
Um,
I'm just doing it a different way than,
than you've chosen to do it.
I'm doing it in a more proactive way
than you've chosen,
you know,
think about it.
And so I would,
if,
if a vet came up to me and be like,
listen man,
there we have more similarities in my
opinion,
than we do differences.
We've just chosen the difference.
The one big fat thing that's different.
It's the difference though.
It's the most important difference.
You want to kill animals need them.
They don't think you should be allowed
to.
They don't think it's right.
They don't think it's moral.
They don't think it's an ethical.
I just think everything is wrong with
what you're doing.
But we both care about animals.
That is a fucked up way to look at.
I care about people too.
I just like to eat them being great.
I'm going to be president,
but I'm gonna.
Eat five people a week.
I don't know.
Imagine if you run for president and
say,
I really love people,
but I like to eat them.
It was a well there.
Those are people.
Don't eat them.
I don't want to be that simple to tell
you about animals.
I would say.
I'm telling you that by,
by taking the lives of these few
animals,
I'm working on the full,
the full breadth of tell you if you
really cared,
you just donate the money.
You just Donate the money to
conservation.
Fuck the pittman robertson act just,
I'm still feed my family.
I'm still making myself a better person.
I'm still enriching my fucking life,
so don't tell me I don't have the right
to do that because you think animals are
sent to you and you're still killing
animals by driving on roads and eating
corn and doing the things you're doing
right.
But they're not directly killing them by
their food choices.
Well,
they don't know they are so into like,
proxy killing is better than than actual
killing.
Well consciously,
right?
Okay.
Actual consciously killing or buying
something that's actually consciously
killed is different than if you buy.
If you buy soy,
if you eat tofu,
there is a fact,
and that fact is,
there has to be a lot of animal
displacement in order to make that
amount of field available,
to grow soy or to,
to grow,
um,
soybeans.
Then it's just the fact.
And then when you talk to anybody that's
ever seen what happens when a crop gets
hit by a combine and then the vultures
start flying overhead,
there's a reason it's because there was
a bunch of little fucking squirrels and
rabbits and all sorts of shit that just
got ground up and anything else that
gets stuck in that field as those
gigantic machines come worrying by.
And that's what.
That's how when you're talking about
large scale agriculture,
that's how things are harvested.
Of course,
they're not plucked one by one.
Now,
if you're one of those people that has
an organic garden and you pluck one by
one,
you take your rotten apple cores and you
fucking orange peels and you throw it
all in a compost pile with some dead
leaves.
And,
and you use that as fertilizer,
you're going to run out of nitrogen
because you need fish.
Bitch.
Oh shit switched from devil's advocate
folks.
Guess what?
WheN you buy a fertilizer is dead fish
this.
Look,
there is a fucking unusual cycle.
It's really weird.
But that cycle is that dead animals
actually fueled the plants that you
consume.
So if you're a person that is,
you know,
if you're,
even if you're eating wild plants right,
you want to eat some wild plants,
guarantees I'm dead fucking squirrels
and rats and pigeons and anything else
went to fertilize,
fertilize.
You probably had that mean they've
proven that there's salmon dna sometimes
In plants because those plants have
actually used salmon for a fertilizer.
Like people have used that,
those dead fish and that shit gets into
the plants themselves.
Yeah,
it's all.
It's all very strange,
man.
There's no way out man.
There's no way out of this,
but in their eyes even there was no way
out.
It's the out.
It's the path of least pain and
suffering and
I would tell those folks,
I respect the shit out of that and I'm
trying to do.
I'm trying to take my own this into my
own hands and actively go and do the
thing that I know to be enriching to my
life,
to make me a better person,
to make me a more skilled person,
to give me more perspective on the
world.
But at the end of the day,
the byproducts of all that activity is a
healthier ecosystem and more more
wildlife because that's proven via the
model we've said,
and I feed my family with that and I'm
just trying to do what you're doing in a
more tangible way.
Your hands off I'm hands on is the way
that I would say that and I respect
the hands off.
I respect like that.
I'm cognizant of what's happening here
and I'm trying to make it better.
I respect that.
I feel what you're saying and I see what
you're trying to do,
but if I'm thinking through the eyes of
a vegan,
you can go fuck yourself.
I'm being the nice guy near him.
A dick floods like vegans.
A lot of them are dicks because wiling
net animals,
you kill the animals.
He fucking asshole.
You think you get a free to just kill
animals and time you on or you don't.
Some of them.
So I like this devil's advocate side of
you,
joe.
Thank you.
Did you see my moby ever look at moby's
page in every movie has a wonderful
instagram page.
Be something that was so preposterous
the other day and I read the comments
under it.
I was like,
this is so hilarious,
but eggs and this is what I mean.
First of all,
folks of talking to a person who has
chickens,
eggs are lIke the most karma free thing
says eggs cannot legally be labeled as
healthy,
nutritiouS,
or safe to eat.
First of all,
this is true because eggs are full of
cholesterol and saturated fat and
because every year over 100,000
people in the us contracts,
I'm going to salmonella from exit.
They cannot legally be advertised as
healthy or safe or nutritious.
First of all,
there's central.
Okay?
I don't know why you post that.
Maybe you didn't look into it.
Is there something called animal
equality?
How many people get salmonella from eggs
every year?
Because if it was 100,000
dollars to fuck,
that shouldn't be in the news would
collapsed so god damn fast.
So let's dismantle.
Please,
please go ahead and do that.
Does dismantle this preposterous idea
that 100,000
people get salmonella.
Okay,
here we go.
Even with safety steps in place,
it is estimated that about one in 20,000
or one in 10,000
eggs are contaminated with salmonella.
Wow.
That's a lot,
right?
What does he,
what did he say?
100,000
people get it.
Right,
but we'll see if you could find how many
people in the u s contract.
Salmonella.
Okay.
Because if they find out
that this salmonella and eggs,
are they finding out that's from
uncooked eggs every year.
About a million people get salmonella
infected from foods that had been
contaminated by one of the many kinds of
salmonella.
Is he right.
Okay.
Let's see if it's 100,000
people from egs.
How many people per year get salmonella
from eggs?
Where does it say salmonella in the
United States?
One hundred and 42,000
people in the United States are infected
each year with salmonella.
Whoa.
Hold on.
That says from chicken eggs.
Wait a minute.
One hundred and 42,000
people in the United States are infected
each year with salmonella from chicken
eggs and about 30 die dude.
Not only It's not going to be right,
but he's off by $2,000.
now you're going to be way more of a
devil's advocate.
Then.
I'm gonna hit you hard with this out
there.
Let's go.
What'd you do?
Have any egg or egg related?
What does it actually kind of salmonella
salmonellosis.
That's it.
Guess what it is when you get it.
So we found that this is true.
Not only is it true,
it's from 2010,
maybe it's different in 2000 1800 42,000
people in United States are infected
each year with salmonella and enter itis
syndromes and darius and titus
underwriters from chicken eggs and about
30 die something last 30 pussies in
2010.
And analysis of death certificate.
Joking,
joking.
It's just a.
The podcast we're in.
The comedy section of itunes identified
1,316
salmonella related deaths from 1990 to
2006.
Whoa,
whoa.
Now thanks moby.
But this is a problem.
These fucking dummies are eating them
raw.
This is what I want you to google.
How nutritious are eggs?
How about google this?
Because a lot of ways of looking at
situational fucking life have never
gotten salmonella.
Pretty good.
You're doing fine,
by the way.
If you eat chicken raw,
you get salmonella to stupid.
You're not supposed to eat it raw.
I supposed to cook it.
Okay.
One egg has only 75 calories,
but seven grams of high quality protein,
five grams of fat,
and one point six grams of saturated fat
along with iron vitamins,
minerals,
and character carotinoids.
The egg is a powerhouse of disease
fighting nutrients like lutein and
zeaxanthin.
Okay,
mavi.
So shut the fuck up.
They're super,
super nutritious for you.
Just occasionally back off moby,
somebody gets salmonella.
How about just cook your fucking fucking
a grow.
But here's where it gets really dark.
Why don't you google this?
How many people die every year from
ecolab?
From vegetables.
That's right.
Because a shitload anti corn is actually
from farmed animals.
It's actually from agricultural runoff
from the.
Let's google.
How much methane comes from how much
methane comes from vegans?
Broccoli?
It's dead like hell.
Let's go back to this like where do you
play the vegan?
So right.
He's not right.
He's,
he's more than 40,000
moby please.
Just six degrees of moby dick.
Edit your post with the correct.
You're right about like eggs or
dangerous pro.
Delete them wrong.
I could die and don't eat them raw
stupid.
Okay.
Here it goes.
Cdc estimates 260 265,000
infections occur each year in the United
States of eco lie.
Wow.
Thirty six percent are caused by
[inaudible] zero.
One five or seven point eight slash
seven.
Dude,
it's almost all from animal agriculture
is almost all from uh,
from shit,
from shit water types of ecolab.
The rosalind can be transmitted through
contaminated water or food to contract
with the animals or people.
Yeah.
But when they say contaminated water,
what they really mean is that water's
contaminated with shit from animal
agriculture.
I think almost entirely.
What is the source of eco lie?
The google this most prominent source of
eco lie from vegetables,
I would guarantee you it's um,
animal agriculture.
I mean if you see those gigantic factory
farms,
the runoff and most prominent source of
ecole lion vegetables.
Is that what you said?
You're better at this than just
configure it.
Get it.
Joe,
do you find it?
You find the evidence?
I'm trying to be.
I'm trying to be a good moby.
Yeah.
I'm trying to be a vegan.
I'm not arguing for the vegans on
vehicles like this.
I like this.
It's not hard to do.
It's hard to do.
It's it.
It's a respectable position,
man.
It just is.
It's all three actually was probably one
of the thing that popped up as the most
common way to acquire e coli infection.
It's unpasteuRized milk.
Fresh produce and fresh produce means
not cooked,
so if you get broccoli,
you have like a.
Yeah,
just spin it.
You're supposed to cook spinach,
celery,
and that's the problem with romaine
lettuce.
Right?
Because romaine is.
Nobody ever cooks at stupid fucking
shit.
Fuck.
At least the world had no romaine
lettuce.
Do you think you'd be okAy?
I think it'd be fun.
Dad calls it the hard lettuce.
He's like,
I don't want that hard.
Let us give you the soft.
Oh,
I don't like giving soft lettuce.
Iceberg is just a joke.
It's just room for meat.
I couLd be putting meat in my stomach
instead of that shitty ass.
Delicious.
The lettuce.
Yeah.
Listen,
I would say to you joe rogan,
vegan,
I would say you're very handsome,
man.
Like you've seen healthy.
Healthy is.
Fuck you have an organic garden.
Your backyard.
Uh,
no,
no.
I got some shit.
I grow a little bit,
a little bit.
Not a lot.
Get a lot of the store,
be honest with you to meet and I don't
buy meat from the store.
Like I,
I get,
I get to opt out of factory farming
because I have a lot of wild game stuff
in my house.
I have definitely still bought meat from
the store.
I buy way less of it and I eat meat
almost every day,
but I'll still go to a restaurant and
order a steak.
Yeah.
I feel like this is something that
attributing people probably heard
before,
but it's like the feeling of eating
while gaming is just different.
It's way different.
It tastes different.
It's better for you.
It feels different.
It feels different for my body,
you know?
I mean I have.
I remember watching this thing about ted
nugent once.
I was like,
how's that goIng?
I got so much fucking energy.
I mean,
he's like 65 years old at the time
period of the.
Well,
he's eating deer every day,
all day,
all day.
I mean,
is it love or hate that guy.
There's a lot of power to his diet.
He's a good guy.
You get to know him.
He really is like,
people are saying to me like,
you good job ted nugent,
the podcasts.
I love him.
How about that?
Does he say things that I agree with 100
percent of the time?
No.
I love ever sat and talked to uncle ted,
which uh,
you know,
shit.
I worked at the nra for a while and like
I used to get assigned
to the ted nugent that talk that he gave
at the nra annual meetings.
Like,
um,
I was a writer for the nra and like work
for the digital websites and I would get
assigned to like the ted nugent seminar
at the nra annual meetings.
I would go and sit in the back with ted
and he brought his brother and he gets
crazy.
He's not fake.
He ain't faking that.
They didn't like something he just puts
on for the cameras.
That's ted,
but he is smart man like he is.
As you found out on that podcast,
which I thought was amazing,
like that dude Is sharp as they come.
You don't want.
Also,
he's reasonable and open to new
information.
You don't wanna think I turned them on
to marijuana.
Yeah,
you did.
Okay.
First of all,
he's using cbd on a regular basis.
In fact,
if you go to ted nugent official,
go to his fucking.
His instagram.
He was actually,
he was advertising jumbo cbd that I
hooked him up with some serious knee
pains because he's had a,
you know,
he was telling me about his days of rock
and roll,
jumping off of amplifiers and he
destroyed his meniscus.
His knees are shot.
I ran into him like three years ago at a
concert and went backstage and we were
chatting and he had a huge ice packs
when each one of his knees and he had
just had surgery on one.
I don't know what the surgery was for,
but it like he had clearly he was
clearly in pain and like he just looked,
you know,
rundown.
But then we went out in the crowd.
He came on stage and it looked like a 25
year old rocca he
fucking,
he's a hard working man.
Yeah.
I mean when,
when the time comeS and the lights are
on,
that guy goes after it and people like
to.
So your support with the racist things
you said or there's like no unfortunate,
you know,
whatever the fuck he said that you
didn't like that either he shouldn't
have said or maybe you didn't understand
what he meant or maybe it's out of
context.
Anything that hurts anybody's feelings.
Unfortunate and donald support it.
But guess what?
We're all.
We all have unfortunate things about us.
That's just a fact of being a fucking
human being.
And one of the parts.
One of the things that we're doing when
we're screaming out and calling out
someone and we want someone deep
platformed and dismissed and never,
never to be heard from again.
We're worried we're part of us are
worried that that's going to happen to
us.
We're worried that we would ever exhibit
that sort of reprehensible behavior or
language and we,
we wanna,
we wanna put a stop to it in ourselves
and other people.
We want to eliminate it from our society
and culture and want to do it harshly
and ruthlessly and were terrified that
it's going to be done to us.
Yeah.
You know,
and there's a Lot of people that make
some fucking really terrible mistakes
and I think there's gotta be some sort
of a path to redemption.
I really,
uh,
really believed that
because I meet,
you know,
in hunting,
I'm certainly don't meet the caliber of
folks that you have in this room,
but like I meet these people in
huntington and I run around in circles
and people are saying,
this person thinks this.
And have you seen that instagram posts?
I don't believe in that.
And like knocking people down,
you know,
and um,
I just think that I know that person,
a good person,
you know,
and maybe he's not,
he or she is not depicting this and the
way that you like it in this instance,
but that's a good well meaning person.
People are more than capable of mistakes
and we should be more than capable of
allowing them redemption and forgiveness
since we should want the same thing for
us.
Should I be on this podcast right now
and have said something in the last
couple of hours that was,
was terrible.
And like I would hope the folks that
know Me would know that like this is a
mistake and as long as I own up to the
mistake and say,
hey,
uh,
it was in the moment,
I apologize a little bit of right brain,
a little bit of brain,
but brain was going,
I apologize for,
for,
for that thing.
And it's not.
That doesn't define me because that's a
very scare and slippery slope to get
down as like one moment in your life.
Can't define.
Yeah.
It's also something that's really,
it seems way more recent,
this,
this idea that,
you know,
you want someone to never be heard from
again.
They fucked up and they should never be
heard from again.
And also I think,
and this is my own bias,
I think it's a product of a shitty way
of distributing information that has
existed all of our lives until recently
and I feel like the long form
conversation is the only way to get to
know somebody and when you sit.
When I saT down with ted after the three
hours talked to mike,
I like this guy.
I liked him.
Well,
like you say,
I love when I get off of a good podcast
when I,
when I was like an episode of the
hunting collective and I sit down with
somebody and they're like,
oh my god,
this person is like,
what?
They just brought to my life in two
hours.
I'm so fucking happy to have had that.
Yeah,
it's like a high you get.
It's a legitimate high because you
don't,
you say this all the time.
You don't get to sIt down in your life
and take two hours or three hours with
somebody in just talk and exchange ideas
and disagree and agree and no
distractions,
no distractions,
and that like what that gives you and
if,
if folks haven't done that,
like that gives you something every,
almost every time.
That's the only way you get to know
people.
It's really,
it's very.
I mean,
I don't mean just through podcasts.
I mean in your life,
meaning if you don't have a podcast,
sit down with someone to talk to them
for several hours and how,
how often do you do that with your wife?
No,
man.
It's fucking rare,
you know?
I mean I have made a vested interest in
long form conversation,
not just on the podcast but In my life
really over the last like five or six
years.
Yeah.
Who better than you did say that and be
like,
this has informed the way that I think,
the way that it's impacted our society
in our culture,
this show,
like it changed the
way I feel about being change the way I
feel about what communication is like.
I ha,
I have convenient perceptions of people.
I think we all do our conveniently go,
oh,
that guy's cool,
all that guy's not,
or this girl's an asshole or whatever,
whatever.
My convenient perceptions of people.
I find that a lot of them are based on
these brief,
brief interactions.
They're based on,
you know,
small amounts of information that's been
distributed over long periods of and
maybe one at one time I caught someone
when they were hammered and they were
being an asshole or maybe I was hammered
and I just,
I was annoyed by them or who knows what
it was,
but to really understand who a person
is,
you have to sit down with them I think
and just talk to them and you have to do
it for a long time and it takes a long
time and you also observe their actions
and observe them when they're tested and
they're observed though,
under duress
and there's no way to get out.
LIke get out of a long form
conversation.
You can't say like,
hey,
I gotta go now.
Yeah,
I'm,
I'm out of my depth.
All the things I said about myself.
How great I was before this.
Now you're opening up this chasm where I
don't know the thing that I said I knew,
but I could for a 32nd one minute tv
spot.
I could train,
I could,
I could read the lines and I could come
off like I look like I know what I'm
talking about.
There's no way to escape this.
This freakIng thing.
I just thought about something like how
fucked up would a show be if you had
just a husband and wife alone in a room
with no one reacting to them,
right?
Just them sitting down at a podcast and
that podcast gets broadcast to the world
and the whole world gets to wash their
fucked up dysfunctional relationship and
how it plays out.
All the weirdness.
You know,
the.
There's weirdness that you see around
people and their wives are.
Sometimes you have a couple of
cocktaIls.
The wife will say something really
shitty and
it's like a cup that spills over.
Like you're just like keeping all of it
in the cup and then every once in a
while you can't keep it in,
keep it in.
And then there's this,
like the guy does something,
do she or the girl does something conti
or whatever the fuck it is.
And then you're like,
whoa.
It first starts to,
it starts to trickle out and this
passive aggressive way.
And then eventually if you're there long
enough it just becomes aggressive.
There's no power on them long enough.
and that's one of the things about
alcohol.
It's so beautiful how that aggression
comes out of people.
Okay,
I got you.
Tell me if you liked this,
you tell them if you liked this idea.
I had this idea the other day.
It basically what we're doing it now is
that I would do a show about ethics
around like hunting and the outdoors and
things,
but it would just be called drunk ethics
where I would just be drinking with
people and having intelligent
conversations that will increasingly get
more and more fucking weird,
horrible fucking weird and open because
I'm getting drunk drinking.
I'm drinking right now through this
whole thing other thAn other than the
fact that I had to pee.
Like yeah,
it's been great.
Yeah.
I'm not a.
I'm not anti drinking.
I think there's something to be gained
from the release of inhibitions and now
there's something that's.
I mean,
there's a reason why it has such a
strong place socially
we'll plug for right brain.
I mean,
I'm releasing inhibitions,
but also increasing brain function at
the same time.
Your brain is so confused.
Hashtag.
It's like,
what,
what is their hashtag?
Right?
Um,
I think there'll be a wicked podcast
every week.
You get together.
A couple that's been fighting tend to go
over there.
I feel about
things.
Maybe have a therapist in the room
thought that there was no therapist will
ruin everything.
That's true.
People fight should just break up.
It's just duke it out until they can't
take it anymore.
Then just,
just go With a way of ben affleck and j.
Lo just fall for a short period of time.
You were in love.
Let it hit the rocks.
Move on folks.
Don't you want to have a new person in
your life?
Do you have any listening?
Do you have any like,
um,
marriage advice?
Like I've been married for coming uP on
five years.
I have a two year old.
My wife wants to have more children.
I just bought a new house,
living in a brand new house in a new
town.
You got a lot of things going on that
are pressure points it living the
American dream a little bit.
I'm very happy with my family.
They're wonderful people.
I love them,
but like I want to sustain this.
I have a great thing.
I'd like to put my arms around to keep
grads is so great.
I don't want it to go away.
Well,
just that attitude alone,
your your awareness of how special it
is.
you know you are doing the thing that
everybody thinks of when they think
about like fulfillment in life.
You're raising a child,
you're having children,
you're,
you know you're engaged in this intense
relationship with another human being.
We've created a person.
All those things.
Those are giant man.
There was a giant also.
You're engaged In an activity that 50
percent of the people fail and they fail
at.
It fucking goes down.
He goes down hard and screaming and
swearing and lawyers of all the levels
of failure in life,
like there's nothing more.
No faIlure,
more impactful than a divorce.
I mean,
if I have so many friends that have been
fired from jobs and it's not fun,
it's not good,
but they bounced back.
He bounce back.
I've seen guys lose who they are from
divorce.
I've seen it happen.
I've talked about this too many times,
but it's a true story.
I have a friend who has been divorced to
a woman for 14 years.
he's been married to a new one for 12.
He has family.
He has children with this new woman.
It's over with the old one.
He still pays every year and they had no
children because he fucked her so hard.
She got work.
It's because it's crazy because the laws
are insane.
The laws are insane.
They don't make any sense.
We're not talking about a woman who was
like 80 years old and can't work anymore
either.
When we're talking about completely,
you know,
viable human being,
students,
bananas did his banana foR that to flip.
Like you said,
when,
when back to the I do thing like when
you say I do,
there's never.
I did have a buddy who when he said I do
and they turned around,
She looked mad.
He looks scared.
Why was she mad?
I probably that she didn't say it right?
Yeah,
he did say that some people just don't.
They're not supposed to be together,
but they think they should be somebody
until they find somebody in the talk
that someone into doing something
fucking insane.
Like signing a legal contract that says
you're going to be together forever and
ever until death.
But see like what my problem is a very
lucky problem that I've got something
that at least in the early years it
seemed to be the right thing.
Right.
I love you honey.
Hope you ain't listen.
She made it this far.
What are we two hours and what?
Thirty minutes?
Yeah,
she,
she's,
she's got a two year old by herself at
home shame.
She checked a long time ago,
but I like,
you know,
my challenge right now is I think about
life.
I'm like,
I got this wonderful,
beautiful thing and I'm just distresses
that I'm going to fuck it up.
Well,
that is,
I'm always the stress and I think that's
one of the reasons why a lot of
marriages fail is because of this
intense pressure of the relationship.
You know,
like there's a finality in and I
understand the need for this banality,
right?
There's a need for this contract and
that everything locked down.
If you're a woman,
you can't win.
You raising children like you need help,
right?
You need a man to be there to help you
raise it hopefully,
but you also need financial help.
It's difficult.
You know,
it's,
this is all.
It makes sense that a woman would want
to lock things in there like that.
It makes sense.
It's also a weird cultural tradition,
right?
It's this weird thing that we have this
law,
like we,
we,
we bring the law involved into
relationships and it's,
it's very strange,
like legal contracts and some of them
are fucking preposterous,
right?
Like sometimes you see a guy who looks
like rupert murdoch,
right?
And he's got this banging wife and she's
like 30 years old and she's got big
tits,
or how about harvey weinstein and his
wife,
she's in it for the right reason and
you're like,
hey son,
I see what happened here.
But he sees it too.
We can't be blind to.
It was his whole business.
When they say I do,
they're like,
well,
okay,
well this is disgusting troglodyte type,
you know,
just gelatinous looking job of the hut
looking man and a beautiful hot young
wife because the guy's got fucking
kajillions.
That's a normal thing.
Then they're both editors put up any
pictures,
but they're both going.
Those folks there,
we were both going into that knowing
like,
hey look,
this isn't a traditional or parents.
maybe he was really sweet with her and
that's all she needs.
She's just this rare soul that if you
had $5 in his pocket,
she'd be super happy with them.
Could be fucking doubt it.
I would doubt it as well.
It is like a motherfucker.
Fuck it.
Fucking doubt it.
Yes.
It's a preposterous union in the first
place.
It's listen,
there's some relationships that you
could define as legal prostitution.
They are absolutely legal prostitution.
A woman has made a determination that
she will let this sloths fluid into her
vagina on an intermittent basis.
If she could be bathed in diamonds and
drive a ferrari and live in a mansion
and this is a normal part of life.
Some people would say,
and I might even say like as long as
they're consenting and they're both
aware that's going on,
then that would be a good argument for
prostitution as well though,
wouldn't.
It's a bit of a transaction I guess.
I don't know.
It's a transaction.
Yeah,
I guess.
I guess when you look at it,
it is right that way.
I've always said,
why is it okay to give some of them
sosh?
He gives him a massage.
You can't.
You can't even jerk him off like it's
not legal.
That's the government decides who can
touch your penis and the massage
therapist said,
hey,
I really enjoy giving you a massage.
Let's go somewhere afterwards of my own
free will and will jerk you off.
It'd be like,
that'd be fine.
That's fine.
Yeah,
you're right,
you just can't do it.
Right,
but then the confines of the massage
parlor,
it's a public health issue.
Imagine if load smelled like gunshots
and you.
He go to a massage parlor.
It's like a shooting range like fuck is
going on.
This place is a dirty massage place.
I'm out pew pew,
pew
load smelling jesus.
The devil was coming up for a devil.
Purify that man.
Yeah,
I mean there's a lot of laws that are
ridiculous,
but there's.
There seems to be someone who hears the
marriage advice I'm looking for.
I got it.
I maybe it was what we were talking
about earlier.
Maybe it's long form conversations.
Having conversations with each other.
I have no longer respect like respecting
the fact that you can't get through some
of this stuff in a very short time.
I've,
I've always said like,
I appreciate a nice road trip for that
reason.
Yeah.
Hanging out with each other for long
periods of time.
Like I'd much rather the stress of an
airport with the kid and the midwife is
not.
I'd much rather just drive it.
Take the time because you get this like
connection if you can get the phones out
of the way for the passenger,
she just get this connection that you
wouldn't get otherwise.
Yeah.
Doing things together that are unique
that that helps,
you know,
experiencing things together.
But also you also have to both have the
mindset that you enjoy each other's
company and you want to make it work
good.
Yeah.
Some people just don't man.
And this is,
we've all seen that happen,
right?
We've all seen relationships with the
girls just like check please.
And the guy's like,
bebe,
I'm different but it's a 50 like you
said,
it's a 50 50 thing.
So like you have been married for quite
some time and we were talking about
prior to when we were shooting our bows
out there,
like you're like things you've done to
make it work.
Like you,
like your wife and she likes you and it
works and it's been working for a long
time and like the percentages say
that's,
that's what'd you say?
50 slash 50 is it?
Chris rock had a great joke about it.
He said he was 50 percent of the people
leave.
He goes,
he goes,
but how many cowards just stay?
It's like,
relationships don't always work,
but here's the thing.
You don't always know who the fuck you
are.
I'm
a different person than I was five years
ago.
I just am.
I hope I'm a better person.
I'm trying very hard to be a better
person.
I certainly know more about myself.
I understand myself better.
This is a long,
slow process.
I think we are all a work in progress,
right?
And not everybody engages in this work.
So you could be a person who's on this
path of,
you know,
being present and trying to be kinder
and trying to improve and then you have
a spouse,
male or female had just shits on you.
And I've seen that too.
I've seen the two really brutal toxic
relationships where they insult and say
rude things around your friends to try
to fuck with you.
And,
and people get into these relationships
where they would.
They genuinely hate.
Yeah.
But they're stuck together.
And what that does,
the children too,
because I told my dad,
I wrote my dad this letter recently.
It's getting real deep.
Our number three of the podcast we get
real deep.
We're pro nuance.
I'm send it to my dad,
but he won't listen to this book.
I wrote this letter that was like,
listen man.
Because I thought I had seen recently
like his developing relationship with my
son and like shot it,
put this thought in my head that know my
relationship,
my dad,
the,
his caring for me.
The fact that he stayed with my mom.
Then they developed this place for me to
grow and nurture me and allow me to
become a person and the environment.
Like there was a north star for me.
Then I left that environment.
Like I always,
I never wondered what my path was going
to be.
I always could look up and be like that
bond that I developed,
my family,
their love for me is like the thing that
I'm always,
you know,
I'm looking back too,
but also looking forward to.
Because that's what defines me and
regardless of what I do,
I can always fall back on that.
That my dad loves me,
my mom loves me,
I love them and I grew up like with the
strength of soul because I knew I don't
have.
I have friends that came from the same
place that I did.
Same town.
I didn't Maryland that odd on heroin.
They live in the same little suburb
suburbia community that I did.
They had parents that were the same age.
They went to the same high school.
They lived in the same environment.
They went down one way.
I went down another and I truly do feel
that that me going down that way was the
way that my parents like built this
structure around me that was always
route,
that bond and that love and the things
that that's very,
very fortunate and that's in that me
being able to later on in life see how
fortunate I was to have that drove me to
not fail and to not let like whatever
other failures creep into my life
around,
you know,
maybe I'll take drugs.
I had a lot,
lot of friend's place.
I grew up in Maryland.
There's a lot of people succumb to drugs
and alcohol and things like that.
A lot of friends die,
you know,
baltimore's rough spot.
Yeah man.
Um,
I come from a town called hagerstown,
Maryland.
I say like,
come from a town,
but the western Maryland is kind of is a
corridor for interstate 70 and
interstate 81 and there's a lot of drugs
there and there's a lot of my friends
that are either in jail or no longer
around that.
A lot of successful ones too.
But that,
that,
that happened to me and I was able to,
I was able to look at that moment and be
like,
I came from the same place.
They did the same environment,
the same friends,
the same,
um,
the same activities.
We all hunted and played sports and we
all,
you know,
we hung out together.
I went one way.
They went another way.
Do you attribute that entirely or to
your parents or is it possible that it's
like who you chose to hang out with as
well and the activities you engaged in?
Because unfortunately I know people that
were good parents that had kids that
old.
Yeah.
And listen,
I can't look.
I'm not trying to generalize in any way
about,
you know,
any one situation.
My situation was that I could always,
I felt like.
And I told my dad at some point in my
life where I said,
um,
I went to him and I was like maybe 20 or
19 and I said I'm going to get all a's
now.
I'm done fucking around.
Like because I was a c plus student,
I was the dumbest kid in the smart class
through high school.
And there was a,
there was a time in my life where I
realized that like I had to pay back
when my parents and my grandparents and
my family had done for me because I knew
that they'd given me something that not
everybody had.
And I kneW.
I was like,
I know that I have to pay this back and
I got to stop messing around now and go
and do something.
That's interesting because they did a
great job then because sometimes what
happens when people were raised with a
giant safety net of love.
Yeah,
they become unambitious.
They become,
I think I was close to them as boys.
I was close to that a little bit like
fall,
like I'm,
oh,
I'm going to community college and
smoking a lot of weed and and try and
have a good time.
Yeah.
No,
but there was a time of my life.
There was a legitimate time in my life
where I said my dad,
I don't remember it,
but my dad remembers it there.
I just came to him and like it's over
now it's time for me to just buckle down
and get it.
Well,
the difference between a child that
you're taken care of and then someone
who has to be on their own is 10 years.
Right?
An eight year old.
No one expects an eight year old take
care of themselves,
but an 18 year old time to get your shit
together.
That's fucking quick.
It's a hard concept.
Quick to argon concept.
It's,
it's,
it's unbelievably hard and unless you
introduce that child to hard work and
the rewards of hard work and you're in
their life,
you're probably going to set them up for
some kind of failure.
I was extremely fortunate that I found
martial arts follow is that my biggest
struggle in my teenage years and I found
something that was insanely difficult,
but the highs,
the rewards were like nothing I'd ever
experienced in my life,
so I realized like,
okay,
to get really good at something,
you have to be able to put in the kind
of energy that most people are not
willing to do and that's what separates
you from them to find a discipline,
put a massive amount of energy and focus
and that discipline and then be obsessed
with it.
Then the rewards come if you analyze it
correctly and pursue it with everything
that you have,
you're going to figure out how to get
better as long as you don't get really
fucked up along the way.
There was a real possibility of that.
So what I realized early on,
fairly lucky was that all these people
that I saw around me that were engaging
in all this really risky behavior,
really crazy violence and drugs and what
they were doing was looking for thrills.
Yeah,
that's what they were doing.
but they were looking for thrills in an
easily accessible way that didn't
require discipline.
It didn't require years and years of
training and focus and commitment.
It didn't require that what I was doing
was something.
And I was just lucky that I found this
thing.
I just didn't want to get bullied and
picked on.
I was,
I was little.
I wasn't a big kid.
You exerting look some control over your
life.
That was just really.
I was.
I was like,
I can't fucking do this.
I'm tired of being scared of people.
Discard this dude.
Give me this fucking tough guy.
Look and I've got to go the other way
because I'm scared.
I just didn't want to be that.
I didn't want to be that.
I'm so that carried on with me for my
whole life,
but I've seen so many people that didn't
find a discipline and they just bounce
around like a cork at sea forever.
Man,
iT's one of the reasons why I push it so
much.
I was like,
whatever the fuck it is that you can do
that you like to do that's competitive.
like one of the things about competition
is not just that you prove that I'm the
fucking man.
Know what it is,
is hard.
It's fucking cup competition is one of
the hardest things because if someone's
trying to do it and you're trying to do
it,
it's like how much do you want it?
How much more do you want them?
They want it.
And that's,
that becomes this crazy fucking battle
internally as well as.
Yeah.
But you say like all the time say
pressure creates diamonds.
Right?
And in my case,
um,
I,
I realized that I didn't,
I realized somewhere in my life that I
have the opportunity to.
There's not enough pressure.
Right.
I have this like soft,
like you said,
soft thing to fall back on,
which is like,
you know,
middle class family that they'll
probably let me live there in their
basement for songs that relate.
Yeah,
but it's like I had the opportunity to
do that,
but I think I just realized that part of
the reason I wanted to push forward and
do it and find something that I was
passionate about it because I knew that
I had a choice.
I had a choice That I could do.
I could try to do something different or
I could fall back on what had been given
and I felt that what I'd been given was
significant enough to my life that I
owed it.
Know,
did something.
I owed it to drive toward whatever
happiness I could find.
And it was,
it was that the stability of my family
life and it wasn't perfect,
but it was,
it was pretty good.
And rather than sink into
that,
I was like,
I'm gonna.
Just push,
push through that and use that as fuel,
as intelligence.
You know what I mean?
You have an awareness,
you,
you figured out what you can do and
what,
where this can go wrong and you
recognized it and you decided to make
some changes,
not eat.
And I'm sure I like it'll have ups and
downs,
but hunting is a thing that enriched my
life,
truly did.
And then as much as it is problematic in
the way that it's presented in society
in the way that,
that,
um,
people see it when they look at it
through like a shallow lens.
Um,
I can say truly that it's enriched my
life in ways I'll never be able to like
truly,
like I met you through it.
Like I met a lot of people I met,
I've,
and then I've met a lot of good people
through that.
Again,
the problem is looking at it from the
outside versus experiencing the people
that you're meeting.
These are people that are doing
something that's insanely difficult and
it doesn't seem like it is for a lot of
folks.
You look on the outside,
like what do you,
what's so difficult to shoot in an
innocent animal?
Bowhunting,
which is what you and I mostly do,
is one of the most difficult things I've
ever done in my life and I've done a lot
of difficult shit.
It's fucking difficult.
It's incredibly difficult and people
that you meet are not just disciplined,
but they're in great shape.
You have to be like.
There's a physical exertion aspect to it
that's completely ignored and
misunderstood or people are ignorant of
it.
Not that it's ignored and they just
don't understand it.
It's Almost like an athletic pursuit
that sustains life.
It's very,
very.
There's a reason why campaigns is out
there running marathons and ultra
marathon running right now.
He's.
He's not just doing thAt because he
enjoys fitness and he most certainly
does.
He's doing that because it helps him as
a hunter and that took a lot of people.
They're like,
wait,
what are you talking about?
Like that doesn't make any sense.
I've seen hunting.
Yeah.
I mean,
if you listen to this podcast and you
never hunted,
like I wouldn't encourage you to go and
find these people on the internet,
on the social medias and things and
understand that each one of them
represents,
in my opinion,
a layer of hunting,
right?
John dudley represents to me.
I mean he's a wonderful human being,
but like at its core on social media,
he represents the expert archer.
Yes.
That's a layer of hunting that you need
to have if you're gonna be successful.
Campaigns represents the physically fit
hunter and that's a layer that you need
to have if you're going to be ultimately
successful like remy warren represent
like the ultimate predator.
Being able to think about like an animal
does and move like an animal does and
that's a layer that you have to have if
you're going to be ultimately successful
and steven rinella represents the,
the great thinker,
the great theorist and all these are
layers that you have to have at some
level.
To be a good hunter,
to be the best hunter,
to be successful consistently,
you have to know so much and one of the
things when I got into it that was
interesting that steve said to me,
he said,
you're going to really like this because
it has so many layers to it.
It's like there's.
There's a lot of room to learn and grow
and you've never can master it.
No,
you can't.
You get especially bow hunting.
What are the possibilities?
You're gonna run into the same scenario
over and over and over and over again.
Never.
I mean you get lucky a couple of years
in a row,
but eventually you're gonna run into
some sort of a situation where the wind
catches you or something goes wrong.
He stepped on a tree branch and snaps
and it's one.
It's like it teaches you accountability
too because when you release an arrow
you are.
You can say whatever you want,
and I've had all these situations where
I've arrowed landed in place.
I didn't mean it to,
and it teaches is accountability.
It teaches you ultimate accountability
because when you release that arrow,
there's not,
you can't go get it back and if it hits
the animal and a place in wounds and the
animal suffers,
it is on you and there is no way to get
out of it.
There's no way to get out of that
feeling and I've,
I've had,
I don't know about you,
but I've had like months,
months,
like six months of just like,
I don't want to overstate,
it's not hyperbolic,
but like just really a lot of pain
around like I did and I.
It was my fault.
I got lazy,
I was presumptive,
I got too confident.
I just screwed up in the moment.
I don't know what happened,
but I've sent a very sharp object into
the rump of a big elk and it ran off and
never to be seen again.
Well,
the consequences of thAt one motion,
the one movement that's going to release
that arrow are so significant that it
fucks with your head.
That's where what we were talking about,
you know,
we've talked about this many times,
but target panic.
That's what that is.
That's the realization of the
anticipation of the moment and the
consequences,
the understanding of the potential
negative consequences,
and they're overwhelming and they haunt
you.
They don't fuck this up in the.
You never should think,
don't fuck this up.
Yeah,
and to me there's massive parallels with
mma,
martial arts,
but also with pr,
with playing pool,
like if you're about to shoot a basket,
I say to bring it up,
don't mess,
don't mess.
You're going to fuck in
to go where you want,
but also there's no part of pool.
if the ball goes where you didn't intend
it to,
an anImal gets made right?
The consequences are so much so you can
equate the consequences in your mind to
be successful because at some level you
have to write.
It has to be an important motion for you
to,
to really care to do it right.
But there's a real.
And that's why I say like,
one of the reasons why I continue to do
what I do is because this is,
this thing is complex and I see other
people's confusion around it and I
appreciate their confusion and I
understand that it's hard to get and I
desperately want to find ways to like
make it easier.
An analogy would be for pool,
imagine if every time you played pool,
you waited days and days for one shot
and you didn't know what the shot would
be and sometimes you had to shoot it
quickly and if you missed and didn't
make the shot,
an animal would scream out in agony and
die a slow death and you would be for
months.
That's when you think about how
difficult it is to perform under that
moment.
The,
the,
this,
this intense pressure of the one moment.
IT's like nothing else
that stressed me out.
Just thinking about it because it is,
it's real life though,
I guess.
Um,
I think steve rinella probably said it
at some point or you did,
or somebody really smart did this.
Like it's a three dimensional
experience.
It includes like riding a rollercoaster
is thrilling,
but the third dimension isn't there
because when you get off,
nothing happened really.
You got the thrill,
but there was no consequence of the
thrill and really that's kind of the
point of buying a ticket to ride on a
rollercoaster,
getting a thrill without having to take
part in anything substantial with
hunting there is thrilled.
There's fun.
Everybody's seen videos of dudes hooping
and hollering and hugging you and I've
done it around the killing of an animal.
It's not that because I always asked
myself like some really key questions
like,
why is killing gratifying?
Like what's.
What's the answer to that?
Really?
And I was like,
man,
that's going to be hard to explain.
There's a bunch of things going on,
but he hard to explain one to someone
who doesn't know what it is.
One thing that's going on is you just
accomplished something that's insanely
hard to do and you're relieved that
their animal died and that relief
manifests itself in a exuberance.
You high five,
you hug,
he let go.
You go,
fuck that.
You're happy that it happened and it
died quickly.
That's a big part of it.
That is.
That is a part of it.
Yeah,
and I'm.
I'm.
I've made just like post on social media
yesterday around like grip and grins,
grip and grants,
man a year.
You're anti agrippa grid for a long
time.
Gave a big sticking point.
It did explain to grip and grin for the
uneducated.
we were talking about us talking about
this,
about we're going to try to write an
article for the mediator.com
about a pub.
A grip and grin is there's.
I mean there's,
this goes back many,
many years.
I mean it goes back to teddy roosevelt.
it goes back to the turn of the century.
Market heart is like the photos we
showed earlier.
Taking a photo with the thing you just
killed.
His is no new thing to us.
It's as old as photos is the oldest
photos.
Grip and grin just means you're with the
animal,
you're gripping,
its antlers are gripping apart of the
animal and you're smiling and you're
happy that you did that.
Um,
what I think what I would say about grip
and grins is that it's been weaponized,
right?
We,
everybody that's listening to this may
is likely seen the girl with the girl,
the giraffe,
the guy with the lion,
the girl,
the other girl did the giraffe,
the guy with the baboons.
It's been weaponized and it's,
it's,
it's been weaponized to a point where
it's the thing,
the first thing that somebody like say,
like ricky gervais' might.
he finds this thing online.
He eats meat by the way.
He does.
How about that?
Do you ever had him on here?
No,
but I talked to him and opie and
anthony,
so nice guy.
I remember listening to the people
hunting if they eat the meat.
Yeah.
And it's like,
so,
so we've weaponized the term trophy with
weaponize this script and can thing and
the um,
society and we know,
I know that honey is the honey was a
business.
Not a lot of people would buy stock in
it.
I mean there's less people doing it.
It's less relevant to society and the
weapon that a lot of folks are using
that don't like it is this photo and the
photo depicts a person smiling next to
or overtop of a dead animal.
And so at its face it absolutely says
I'm happy that there's a dead animal in
front of me.
It's not enough information for such a
significant moment.
And that's what.
So what I've said around like around the
photo is it happened for a very long
time,
but then social media became a deal.
Right.
And during the eighties and nineties,
grip and grins were like,
I remember going to like my first trade
shows as a kid or in people would have
like flip books of grip and grins.
They would like get them out and be
like,
you see what I killed this year before,
before cell phones or whatever.
They would bring them out and be like,
look at that,
look at all the things I killed.
And it was like this,
this,
this communication between hunters that
was legit.
Like I know what a gripping rain is.
I'm not questioning it,
but then social media becomes prevalent.
people start posting these photos to
everyone where they can control the
messaging anymore and it's,
it's one of the easiest things,
one of the most oxymoronic thanks to go
pluck from hunting and be like,
don't understand this,
this looks fucked up.
Let me apply that to trophy hunting and
let me damn this person for this photo.
And so with that lady with the goat
recently.
Yeah.
Invasive species on an island where they
have to kill it.
It's killing all,
all the native wildlife.
Yep.
but then later on they find that there's
a photo of that young lady with a bloody
dildo and got blood on it.
Did you not hear about that part?
What?
Yeah,
we're going to have to get that on the
old google machine.
Yeah.
That's a tough subject for three hours
in.
But that happened.
Um,
what do you mean?
Just put up stuff that's hard for me to
explaIn this.
There was like a,
some sort of bachelorette party or
something.
And that young lady.
The same lady that was in the skyland,
correct?
Yes.
Um,
with the goat was also photographed with
a bloody dildo goat blood.
I believe so.
Why was she trying to say?
I don't know.
Maybe she just partying.
She could have been just having a great
time.
What if is a photo with me with a bloody
deal though.
You would go figures like at them rogan.
Good.
That jambo jambo dildo.
He's had too much.
Right brain.
I hope I'm right about that and just
make that up.
No,
but we've discussed that internally at a
bunch.
Jamie say hit me up,
jamie.
What's up?
It's like the fist thing.
It doesn't look like it did sound like a
dildo.
Like you're thinking of.
Oh,
it's like a fist dildo.
Is it a.
I'm not going to show.
Oh yeah.
I can show you guys keep it to himself.
There you go.
Okay.
That,
that's,
that's the thing.
Okay.
Oh,
it's
just,
it's a fist.
Is that for fisting?
This is hunter and blah blah blah.
Slam for photo with dead.
She bloody sex toy.
Um,
okay.
That's fox news.
Huh?
So that's recently.
is this recent?
When is this?
Yeah,
this is november.
Remember?
This is recent.
So it's quite a few months after the
Initial image was.
So this is a different animal she's
with.
It looks like some.
She's got one,
she's got there,
it looks like an ibex,
and then she's got what looks like a
moot,
another dead animal on british soil.
um,
she posed with a sex toy and the dead
sheep.
Well,
maybe there's some context to it.
I mean maybe it was a.
I don't.
Like I said I don't.
I lost a bet.
It doesn't look good.
Let's just say that.
Yeah.
In the context of the husband said,
listen,
if you do shoot one,
this is what you have to do a.
Maybe there was a bed that's,
I don't know.
I need the details around.
But that Photo.
Is it just like the baboons one?
Just
don't look good.
what are you saying,
jamie?
Okay.
It says,
gearing said that the marital aid had
been given as a birthday present,
but said swift lik,
how do you say your name?
Swindling,
sweat,
lick.
Sort of rude and arrogant throughout the
trip.
Who's gearing a think?
Must have been her international host.
Maybe she's british.
Jumped on the trip with one of the women
on the trip.
Okay.
Well,
that sounds like two chicks and get
along to hear her side of it.
It was a bit of fun during the party.
We.
Marital aid is given as a birthday
prison
to an hour.
I have no idea why I was brought out the
following day on the hunt.
It was an appalling thing to do.
Please show disrespect to the animal she
did.
She has just killed the animal.
Doesn't know because it was dead and I
don't.
I mean,
it's weird,
but I don't know.
I don't know if I'm horrified by.
I'm not friends with her any longer and
in fact she's the reason that I left
early because I was so against what she
stood for and her more.
I don't want to read this.
Don't know.
Chicks,
chicks.
Ladies,
I love you.
I don't know that person contact with
each other.
I've never met that person.
I don't know them.
but that happens like this.
This is just an example of who knows the
weaponizing of these situations where
somebody dildos get pulled out and
everybody gets upset every time.
Um,
I did not know about that though.
Yeah,
it's interesting.
That's one,
one example,
but that's,
that's what ends up happening around
these images.
Now,
when I posted this thing the other day,
half people would say like,
don't stop doing what you're doing.
If you feel it's right and you feel
respectful as a hunter and you're
telling the entire story,
and part of that story is to sit behind
the ambulance,
smile and and signify how great you feel
about it.
Then go for it.
Exactly.
That's what you should be doing.
Don't let someone else change your
behavior.
The other side of things is like every
hunter has a chance to impact somebody
that doesn't go hunting.
Every hunter,
there's 11 million hunters.
They have a chance to impact the
millions and millions of folks who
aren't exposed to hunting at any point
in their lives,
and so I can see.
I can really see both things,
but for me it's.
It's an issue of if I want honey to
continue in the way that it does and I
want my social media privileges to make
hunting better,
I would probably choose not to put that
out there unless it was in the context I
felt very comfortable with.
That's very fair.
It's not just fair,
it's honest and um,
it makes sense,
but obviously if you had those photos
and you show them to someone like me
who's hunted,
it wouldn't bother me at all and be
like,
oh,
you got a nice deer.
It's all about context.
It's all like I could slide it across
the table to you or texted to you and
you would say,
cool man,
congratulations.
You and I have been on several hunts.
We know what it's like.
We,
we,
there's no,
we don't have to explain what it is.
The problem is it's like fast food for
an idea.
You're just,
it's a tiny little thing.
It's not real.
You're not,
you're not getting the full context of
where the food came from or how the
animal was raised and how was killed and
turned into a burger.
You just getting the burger real quick
and this is what you're getting with the
photo.
You just getting a photo.
Yeah.
not getting the full context of the
experience that led up to you shooting
this deer that might be like this 200
inch mule deer.
that's the deer.
Have a lifetime.
You have this giant smile on.
You're like,
believe you outwitted this old monarch
of the forest and put an arrow in his.
Ah,
his,
his rib cage
for sure.
And I.
And I think that that's a totally
legitimate way to express your hunting.
For me.
If you were to ask me today,
I would say I would probably not give
anybody the chance to misrepresent my
shit.
I don't put pictures like that up
anymore.
You don't.
Same reason,
but I don't in the past,
but I've put a lot of elk meat up.
Woo.
For me it's like I,
I put the meet up,
I put all the whole story up,
but if I was to say,
like I always said in the very beginning
of the whole me not liking grip and
grins conversation,
I said,
if,
if someone had said,
ben,
can you give that up for the betterment
of haunting?
Like could you just give that one thing
up?
That's traditionally it's been done for
decades or for a guy kills the thing
that sits in front of it.
Yeah.
would you be willing to give that up if
for some way,
shape or form?
Even if you didn't agree with it,
it made for a better hunting to hunter
to non hunter relationship.
I was like,
fuck yeah man.
Yeah,
I'm down for that.
and so I think that's what the
conversation is now is trying to
determine is that the best thing or not.
I,
I'm not sure I have the answers.
I think for anybody who's listening to
this three hour conversation and sort of
gets an understanding of where we're
coming from,
they'll appreciate that there's a lot of
thought involved here.
For anybody that sees that photograph of
you smiling with a dead bear,
they're not going to appreciate that and
it's going to be real quick and they're
gonna have this.
How many people are willing to sit here
and listen to this whole conversation
and get to get an understanding of how
your works and
how you think about things.
Not nearly as many as we'll look at a
photo and go,
that guy's a cunt,
you know,
and that's the ricky gervais' tack,
right?
As much as I do enjoy re ricky's comedy
and when he looks at these things like
that,
first of all,
that fucking giraffe one,
that's a rough one,
was super complicated and glenn
greenwald and all these other people,
they sicked a lot of people and that
lady,
that giraffe had to be killed.
That giraffe apparently had killed at
least two or three bowls and it was a
non-viable male and they made it out
like it was just rare giraffe.
It's rare because it's old.
It was dark because the dark ones or
older ones,
but that's.
We always get down these rabbit holes.
They think somebody says,
I'm mad about this photo and the next
thing we know we're debating the age of
a fucking single giraffe because like it
matters.
It does matter,
but it doesn't matter to the extent that
they try to make it.
They don't understand what they're
looking at,
but they are looking at something that
they find displeasing.
Yes.
And that's,
you're right about that.
And I find a displeasing as well.
I'm like,
when I see that,
listen,
I'm not a giraffe hunter.
I've never been to that part of africa.
I don't know that person,
but just to look at that,
I feel the same way as everyone else
because giraffes are awesome.
The thing about dress,
I had a bit about my act like they're
the only animal that looks fine with
being in the zoo.
Yeah.
Like another day with no lions,
just strolling around babies feed
giraffes.
My fucking daughter,
when she was two,
I held her up and she had a piece of
leaf and she put it out there and the
draft comes over.
It's the only animal that they let
babies feed.
They don't let little kids feed polar
bears.
Fucking piller piller fuck you.
Let it be dining on fingers.
Yeah.
Give me your arm man.
So I,
I get.
You're right.
No,
you're right.
It might make sense.
I want it to be better.
I want the conversation between,
not between the ricky gervais',
ricky gervais' acts like an asshole in
this context.
He enjoys getting angry people,
but in his defense,
the stereotypical hunter that is in his
mind what he's fighting against is an
asshole.
Yeah.
And I would agree and I would be like,
dude,
I agree with you.
Most agree with you.
Fat guy wants to fly to africa and shoot
an elephant and is not even going to eat
it.
And he just wants it because he's
getting the big eight.
There wasn't.
There's a lot of weird shit.
Yeah,
problem.
The problem I have with that is like
this specifically calling out that
single person or a smaller group subset
of hunters that you don't agree with to
paint the entire group like that.
They think that that's the only way they
can get people to stop.
They think that what they've done with
cecil look,
they enacted real change.
There has been real change around a lot
of this stuff with with cecil.
They enacted real change,
but unfortunately a lot of it has been
negative with people don't understand is
how much it costs.
The people that lived there and about
these hunting concessions get closed
down and then these animals go wild and
then what happens is poachers just take
over and a lot of the animals get the
same way
they did in the United States before
market hunting was outlawed.
When you look at what,
what a concession is,
right?
A concession in this happen,
I want to say it happened in like the
late seventies and early eighties in
africa where there was especially
antelope and african antelope and all
these other species that were there.
They were.
They were not at the brink of
extinction,
but they were suffering.
A concession is essentially a bunch of
ranch land owners get together and be
like,
let's put a fence around our stuff to
keep everything,
keep poachers out and keep the animals
in.
Once you know,
in africa wins,
especially south african.
When concessions became prevalent,
a wildlife populations skyrocketed,
you know,
tripled,
doubled times 10,
hundreds of thousands of analysts that
were there before.
They're actually.
Because that's the only way they could
have value value because they have
monetary value.
Yeah.
And I'm not.
I'm conflicted about that too.
Yeah,
I'm conflicted about it.
It's like a thing that worked,
but is that the way I don't.
I don't know.
I've been over there.
I'll probably never go back over there
because there's just so many things in
this north America I'd like to pursue,
but like it's something that I was
involved,
like I went and did and I realized,
hey look,
this is way too complicated and,
and if there's too much way too much
american influence based on the money we
bring you over there,
that isn't rooted in exactly what's good
for africa.
Right.
So I think like african hunting is
valuable.
It's like you can paint that picture all
day long.
It can be like this is,
it's valuable,
it's value for these reasons and nobody
can really argue like the end result of
the thing,
but what's being argued argued the end
result because it's been so much more
effective than just conservation based
on donations.
Yeah.
And that's what people don't understand
that argue against it.
You're wrong when it comes to the
numbers,
the numbers are wrong.
You would like to think that people
hunting zebras don't help,
but they do.
Yeah.
That's what they help way more than
people that go over there to take
photographs.
Yeah.
So,
so am I willing to say like get rid of
that so I can feel better about hunting?
No,
fuck no.
Because I want there to be more animals.
The number is so different in the amount
of money they contributed.
This is where people have to understand
because they'll throw some numbers at
you like you know,
5,000
people go to safari.
He's only 2000 people,
huh?
Yeah,
sure.
But the 2000 people that hunt,
they hunt and they spend way more
fucking money.
It costs a lot of money to shoot a line.
It costs like $50,000
as much as you find line hunting
distasteful.
You have to understand that if you
remove it,
it's like when you take a dictator out.
Yeah.
And then you have like a power vacuum.
How do you replace it?
Well,
and it's just like they're,
they're just some like on the ground
things that happened to around,
look,
if you want to do wildlife viewing,
you gotta cut roads.
Like you got to put.
If you want to do wildlife viewing,
people are going to pay less.
So it means you have to have more people
encroaching them on these places where
these wild animals are.
You have to make parks where humans
can't go in and you have to be prepared
when humans get attacked by animals,
we're just going to fucking happen.
And so it's never as simple as it seems.
It is as simple as it seems to say like
the numbers say that that african trophy
hunting is benefiting.
But bob life now,
is it benefiting in the way that
everybody thinks is best?
That's debatable,
but you can't.
You can't sit here and say like,
if we end this today,
there'll be more game and be like,
it's probably the reverse is the
reverse.
Probably the reverse.
It might,
it'll hurt your feelings,
but it's the reverse.
Yeah.
Um,
what's going on right now in africa
with.
What were the exact area that cecil the
lion happened in,
is that they had a call,
200 lions.
They had to shoot 200 lines,
which means they had to pay someone to
go and shoot these lines because they
are,
their population had gotten so high.
They were decimating the angelo
population,
so all the antelope and all the
different animals that the lines were
haunting,
they were destroying them because they
have to eat a lot man,
but you're a 600 pound cat and all you
care.
You're a.
You're a meat processor on four legs,
brow,
like there's no.
You can't be like,
hey listen man,
listen,
just lay off for a couple of weeks,
listen another,
do this.
I know you really like to eat.
Also,
you know,
they were just breeding unchecked.
Their populations quickly got to very
unmanageable number.
Well,
it seems it's never as simple as it
seems.
The mountain lions in California,
Washington and Oregon this year in
Oregon and Washington to people,
poor killed one in each state that
hasn't happened in 100 years.
You know,
I've talked to a lot of people that say
that's an anomaly,
but it happened nonetheless.
It doesn't mean anything.
If it's an anomaly.
It's also a reality is it happens are
predators and they're Big and they're.
They've killed I think 55 bears in the
greater yellowstone ecosystem this year.
Just probably that number could be
skewed In some way for me,
but I think that's what I heard a lot of
black bears,
right that invade into,
I think this was,
this was all grizzly bears that had
either been hit by cars or nuisance or
we're getting around somebody cattle
that had been shot.
I think if that's the number,
you have to look that up and confirm
them right about that because that's a
pretty serious accusation if I'm wrong,
but you know that happens in that this.
So there's no simple.
there's no simple way to put it.
Just here with mountain lions mean
mountain lion hunting is outlawed in
California,
but they killed the same amount of
mountain lions and the way they killed
them as they have to hire people and
they have to use public funds,
these tax dollars and they hire a guy
with dogs to go catch these fucking
cats.
KIll them.
Yeah.
I mean,
we.
Hours ago we talked about the north
american model of wildlife conservation,
but that's a thing.
It's not infallible,
but it's pretty fucking close in my
opinion.
It's a very good system and there's more
stuff that we didn't cover but shit,
dude.
Or deep deep.
Three hours into this motherfucker.
How long jamie?
three hours then.
it's a good.
That's a good jerry solid one.
So.
So let's wrap this pitcher.
see ben o'bryan.
I'm glad we did this,
my brother.
Always good to see you.
Great to see you.
You're the man.
Let's go play some techno hot.
Yeah.
All right everybody.
Bye.
See ya.